Five,
three,
two,
one go.
Yes sir.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Sorry.
This episode of the podcast is brought to you by your mother's vagina.
That's how you got here.
Whoa.
So everything's brought to you from that.
Do you personally,
not me,
I don't know your mother.
Just what a terrible way to start a show.
This episode is brought to you by Squarespace.
Squarespace is the all in one platform that makes it fast and easy to create
your own professional website.
And I really do mean professional.
They,
they make fucking amazing websites.
If you go to the desk squad.tv and check out the website that Brian has created
along with the online store that has created,
he did an amount fucking 10 minutes.
It's incredible how easy it is.
Drag and drop interface,
24,
seven support and it works great on everything on Android,
iPhone,
Unix,
Linux,
work on whatever you want.
Windows,
Mac,
PC,
very easy to use.
Um,
plans start at $8 a month.
That includes a free domain name.
If you sign up for a year,
responsive design and your design will look awesome on any device.
Online commerce.
Very easy to set up.
Easy as peasy.
I don't even think that's a real thing to say.
Easy peasy.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
That's what I'm trying to tell you.
Every site comes with an online store.
Really,
really easy to do.
Squarespace has a logo creator.
We can create a clean,
simple design for yourself in minutes and every design automatically includes a
unique mobile experience that matches the overall style of your website.
So your content will look great on everything all the time for a free trial and
10% off your first purchase.
Go to squarespace.com and enter the code word Joe Squarespace.
A better web starts with your website.
We're also brought to you by nature box,
the official snack provider for the podcast,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
That's this one.
It's the one you're listening to.
Nature box.
I'm eating something that shit right now.
If you hear me gum,
that's cause I have Santa Fe corn sticks stuck in my teeth.
I'm a fan.
I'm a fan of all this shit.
Naturebox is a way we can get healthy stamp.
Well,
we'll run this shit by Mike Dolce.
See how healthy it really is.
Chocolate keenwah granola.
How are you going to fuck with that?
My goal charity.
Good.
I'm as good shit dude.
Um,
naturebox has zero trans fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup.
Very,
you can get find snacks that are low in sugar,
non GMO.
If you want gluten free,
you can get that and they ship for free.
I know a lot of you folks work in offices and you know,
sometimes you get hungry and you can't leave the office and you're stuck.
You're stuck with that stupid vending machine.
We're probably,
if you're lucky,
there's peanuts in there.
Most likely it's just bullshit though.
Chips and chocolate bars and all that shit.
You can get naturebox shipped directly to you and you can get 50% off your
months first by going to naturebox.com/rogan.
They have over a hundred different choices for you to try various different
snacks.
I I fucked up and I talked too much about Sriracha.
Cashews.
They'd been out of stock for months now.
It's amazing how easy that works.
Um,
those blueberry almond,
Ooh,
those are awesome.
The dark cocoa almonds.
Those are fucking pretty fantastic too.
There's a lot of great choices with naturebox.
Hopefully they'll figure out a better supplier for their fucking serratia
cashews.
They're too good.
They're that good.
They were the cat.
I'm not bullshitting.
I've had so many people tweet me going,
dude,
you are fucking right.
I thought you were exaggerating.
They're real.
They're legit.
Go to naturebox.com right now for a 50% savings off your first box,
a free shipping.
Go to naturebox.com forward slash,
Rogen.
That's naturebox.com forward slash,
Rogen and last,
but certainly not least,
are brought to you by legal zoom and legal zoom is a way that you can handle a
lot of legal bullshit from the comforts of your own home naked and on heroin.
You can do all sorts of legal stuff and no one can fucking stop you.
You could be drunk,
you could be masturbating.
They can't do a God damn thing about it.
Baking the love,
breaking the law,
but you're not breaking the law.
That's the thing.
You're doing it illegally.
What naturebox is,
is a way that you can get snacks delivered to what legal box is.
Legal box.
Legal Zoom is,
is a way that you don't have to leave your fucking house.
You could just stay put and deal with.
You can get a power of attorney.
You get a personalized will you get a living trust?
Legal Zoom has an a plus from the better business bureau.
Ber Berlin.
That's a weird word.
Need a better word for bureau.
It's a weird word.
It's like some fucking 1800 shit.
Better business bureau furniture.
Yeah,
it's fucking dressing.
It's ridiculous.
But point is whatever that thing is,
the BB,
whatever the better business be.
BBB legal zoom has gotten a plus for them.
Um,
for legal,
legal zoom has for over 10 years,
they've helped protect people's assets with Llcs,
s corporations,
trademarks,
real estate documents,
and more their service developed by some of the best legal minds in the country.
And they make it painless for you to get legal protection that you need.
If you call or visit legal zoom,
they will take care of you from start to finish.
And for special savings,
please make sure to enter the code word Rogan in the referral box at checkout.
Legal Zoom was developed by top attorneys to provide self help services at your
specific direction.
But they are not a law firm.
They can't,
however,
connect you with a third party attorney,
like if you're one of those panicky fuckers and you can't handle it.
So if you,
uh,
if you freak out,
they can,
uh,
they can connect you with someone that tells you don't freak out.
You're going to be okay.
It's easy to do though,
folks.
Very easy,
step by step,
they'll take care of you from start to finish and it's,
it all can be done.
Like so much can be done for a fraction of what it would cost you to paint
attorney to do these things.
Not,
not to mention the fact that you don't have to drive to an office.
You don't have to make an appointment.
You don't have to park no.
That nonsense.
You could do 99% of all that stuff at legal,
zoom.com legal zoom.com.
Make sure you enter the code word Rogan in the referral box at checkout and save
yourself some cash.
All right.
Without further ado,
uh,
I try to keep these things in the minimum.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I know people say to really get you fucking commercials takes so much time.
They don't necessarily have to take so much time.
They take time only because I bullshit during the commercials and also because I
really do try to only have things on the podcast that we use.
Legal Zoom was used by us to start on it.
The death squad.
Dot.
TV legals.
You zoom was used by Brian to start that.
Um,
I only bring things on the podcast as a sponsor that I use legal zoom to get
dolce diet renders the years ago.
Legal Zone.
You fucks.
Come on now.
All right.
That's it.
Boom.
Schelok lock.
Cuban music
experience.
Fitness Guru to the stars.
Mike Dolce my friends.
What's up?
Good to see you brother coming back here.
Cheers to you.
Thanks John.
Thanks for coming on man.
We got a lot of questions.
Got a lot of questions.
Die Questions,
nature box questions.
Granola,
keen Bois chocolate please,
please do good.
There we go.
It's Yummy.
Tell you that it's Yummy as fuck.
You don't have to check that out.
But I want to talk to you about,
um,
a lot of people who don't understand mixed martial arts,
uh,
or,
or maybe they're casual fans.
They don't know that there's a lot going on in a MMA and one of the things
that's going on besides the fact that it's a very dangerous,
very,
uh,
it's a highly charged sport with a lot on the line for the competitors.
But one of the things that's on the line that a lot of people aren't aware of is
a thing that we call weight cutting.
And so I can feel people in that may just not know much about MMA.
If a fighter is going to fight at,
say,
145 pounds,
that's one of our weight classes.
Um,
they probably don't really weigh 145 pounds.
It's very rare that you get a guy like Frankie Edgar who was the lightweight
champion who lightweight in the UFC as 155 pounds.
That's what he actually used to way he was in Rio.
He was really fit and uh,
he walked around at one 55.
He didn't cut any weight to uh,
to weigh in for the weight class and it was always smaller than almost anyone in
his division.
He still won and beat some of the best guys in the planet just cause he's really
tough and very highly skilled.
But that's the rarity.
The only division where that doesn't take place is in the heavyweight division,
which guys don't have to cut any weight at all.
Generally speaking.
There was a few exceptions.
Like Tim Sylvia in his hay day used to be a little bit bigger or Brock Lesnar
might've caught a little or a Alistair Overeem when he first fought in the UFC.
Cut a little.
But for the most part,
those guys get to eat whatever the fuck they want for everybody else.
There's essentially,
there's two different events going on.
There's the event where there's a fight where you're training to compete against
the best mixed martial arts fighters in the world.
But then there's also the way in and the way in is an event in and of itself is
a huge thing because you get guys like a perfect example of extreme examples is
glace and t bow.
I don't think glycines missed weight.
Has He ever missed way?
Not that I know of.
You figured out a way to do it.
They get it done,
but in is fucking enormous.
He fights at one 55 I weigh in the high one nineties and he's bigger than me,
so I don't know how the fuck he does it.
I really don't know how the guy does.
It suffers.
He suffers and he gets down to one 55 for a very brief window of time and then
rehydrates the shit out of himself.
Yeah,
and that's the goal.
Ultimately what we're trying to do is trying to be on wait for the shortest time
possible to minimize the ill effects of being at that weight.
Guy Like Nick Lynch,
one 45 pound,
you're brought up 40 fives so nick lens,
he does most of his training camp around one 75 now.
Whoa,
that's so crazy.
Massive and we want to touch down at 45 and be there for really under an hour.
I want my athletes still kind of dripping that last sweat when they step on the
scale so they can just graze the contract weight and immediately we hydrate them
right back up again.
And when you say nick lense walks around at 175 pounds for folks that are
listening to this,
you're like,
oh,
he gets fat.
No,
he does not know at 10% body fat.
Okay.
That is so crazy.
How is it possible that a guy can be one 75 at 10% body fat,
by the way,
I'm a fat fuck.
I'm about 17% body fat.
Okay,
look leaner than that.
I don't know.
I'm maybe a little self deprecating.
Maybe 15 that's be nice.
Say I'm 15% body fat.
So this guy has 5% less body fat than me and he's going to cut 30 fucking
pounds.
Yeah.
How does a guy do that?
It's through the multistage process.
So when I back up,
when I talk to an athlete or when I talk about weight cutting,
I say number one,
it's not the best case scenario.
Wait,
come.
Weight cutting is something that unfortunately has to be done by a lot of
athletes in order to minimize advantage as opposed to gaining an advantage.
But the weight cut should start 52 weeks before competition,
which means it should be a lifestyle.
These athletes,
and this is what they need to understand and hopefully we can spread this
message,
is they need to be training and living and eating and breathing like
professional athletes 365 days out of the year so they can minimize the downside
of the weight cutting practice.
They need to be eating the proper foods training intelligently,
resting completely so their body's able to endure the grueling practice of
cutting weight.
So with Nick Lens,
he's fresh in the mind right now is just with him in Connecticut last week he
made weight one 46 Charles Allavara his opponent,
he weight by four pounds,
which was absolutely ridiculous.
Unprofessional.
But there's a saying and that,
you know,
the first fight is with the scale.
So the athletes,
when they get to,
you know,
the,
the fight week or when they get the,
the location,
they're focused on the scale.
They don't even think about the fight for the most part.
Is that a good thing?
Does it keep them from getting distracted about the fight?
That's,
yeah,
and that's actually a,
uh,
one in the positive benefits of it is that they're not focused on the fight.
They're not burning,
you know,
all that nervous energy thinking about the fight.
But that sets in pretty quick.
As soon as they step off the scale and they have that first face off,
in that case,
maybe every fighter should have just a really fucking crazy girlfriend,
right.
The vans all their time and the only hook up with,
or the week of the fight so that she just demands all your,
you know,
your all you fucking care about is what you eat.
You don't even care about me.
I'm not even the most important thing to you and just have like the most crazy
narcissistic,
psychotic relationship when the girls should have ridiculous guys.
Wanna check your phone,
check your phone.
Who's fucking touched in you?
You're fucking trainers.
Too little too comfortable with you.
That actually happens.
I'm sure it does.
And for men and for women right now that we have a lot of women in the UFC,
I bet it happens for them more.
Sure.
I bet guys are more psycho with their popular star women girlfriends,
those fucking weird guys that are in the background that aren't famous and they
have famous girlfriends.
Ill mean muggin all the coaches,
partners,
all the reporters,
three free press each and every one of them.
Not really.
I don't do whatever you want to do.
Okay.
But the point is that this is a,
this is a genuine issue and it's a genuine physical issue as well as a genuine
logical issue.
Yeah.
And the amazing training camp,
eight week,
12 week training camp can be blown during fight week or the 24 40 hours,
48 hours before they step in the octagon or you know,
in the competition because they blew their weight cut.
And then even if they do make weight,
typically most athletes,
a large majority,
even at the high level,
they blow their rehydration,
they step on weight.
They think,
oh my God,
I made it.
And they grab a sandwich from the Deli or they go and get,
you know,
Pasta Fettuccini Alfredo from the local Italian restaurant and they eat food
that they haven't eaten in weeks or months before.
They totally screw up their digestive system.
Body goes to shit and they,
you know,
they're a shadow of their former selves.
Well,
I know Chris Leben talked pretty openly about how he did that and one of his
weight cuts,
he ate a bunch of gummy bears.
Yeah.
And he went into shock,
like his body literally like went into like some sort of a sugar shock because
he just couldn't help himself.
Yeah.
I live in,
I've known Levinson's Oh four when I started working up at team quest in Oregon.
So I was his coach for a long time,
work with them for a few fights,
not many of the fights recently.
The Vandelay Silva fight was the most recent fight I worked with them.
That was when it was most spectacular victories of all time.
It was,
and that's when he was so motivated.
And that's the Chris I would have loved to have seen in all of his fights
because he was lean,
he was sharp,
he was ready,
he was confident.
He chased away a lot of the demons and a quick leaving story.
So we backup to a fight.
Previous years before that,
and I had lost contact with him,
hadn't seen him in awhile and I'd see him,
I'm with another athlete in the casino.
I see Lieben and he's,
you know,
he's partying and this is right before the fight.
I'm like,
Bro,
how many hours before the flight?
That's like the day before.
So he's drinking and he's,
well,
he,
he's,
he's reeking of it,
you know,
I,
yeah,
I partying and whatever,
whatever,
you know you're going to fight.
God,
I don't know.
Hopefully by the end of the show I'll remember who it was and I think he
actually won the fight,
which is insane.
I mean,
I've got multiple leaving stories,
but I was like,
Chris,
what are you doing?
And he's like,
dolce sometimes he's just got a dance with the girl you came with.
And I was like,
motherfucker.
All right.
All right Chris.
You know,
high five,
good luck.
And I'm pretty positive he did go out there and win that fight.
Oh,
I would imagine he did.
He's a wild motherfucker for real.
That's a,
that's a great quote from leaving because that is literally how he got there.
He got there being a wild man.
It's exactly what gave him his edge and what got them to the top.
Yeah.
Is this a weird,
yeah.
Maturing process,
isn't it?
For some fighters where they got into fighting because there were so wild and
reckless and somewhere along the line they have to be cautious and calculated.
They have to really think of themselves as pro athletes.
And I say that not just about their training and diet,
but also about their approach to fighting itself.
You know,
I think I'm a huge Forrest Griffin fan.
I love forest it just as a person and I'm a huge fan of his as a fighter.
But I think that one of the best and worst things that ever happened to him was
that fight.
With
that.
Like I would say it's one of the greatest,
most important fights in MMA,
but the fight with Stephan Bonner in the finals of the ultimate fighter the
first season,
which was such a crazy fight,
people don't realize how bananas this situation was.
Spike TV was a new network.
It was like some fucking country music channel or something before that,
right?
It,
wasn't it the country station or some shit and it became spike,
which was like a the the guys channel and then they put on this thing,
the ultimate fighter and then,
you know,
people watched it.
It was a good show.
But in the finals,
Stephan Bonner and Forrest Griffin went on it one and it's so hard that the
ratings went through the roof.
Like they can monitor the ratings while the fights going on.
And it went from,
you know,
like a million people watching it when first started to like 10 million people
at its peak,
which is insane,
which they can track is directly related to people calling each other up and go
and dude,
you got to fucking see this turn on channel two 48 these motherfuckers are
throwing down.
And then people started calling each other and then the see through the fight as
the,
it was a while fives because you got two guys who knew each other super well
trained together for,
you know,
the six weeks they were in the house and then went to war.
And they were so evenly matched that it was,
there was no winner in that fight at the end.
Forrest Griffin one,
he got the decision,
but it was so close that we,
we actually talked about it inside the cage.
I said,
why don't you give you the both these guys a fucking contract?
And they would,
and they talked about it and Lorenzo and Dan like,
let's get both these guys a fucking contract.
And then boom,
they both got this,
this big six figure contract with the UFC.
But that kind of style was so rewarded that it became how Stephan Bonner fought.
Sure.
And I think he's,
he's,
you know,
he's still kind of fights like that.
Um,
but as Forrest Griffin,
I think that it turned out to be his downfall in a lot of ways.
Like this face for charging aggressive style.
And that's how he lost to Keith Jardeen.
And that's,
you know,
I believe like the more strategic Forrest Griffin was the one who beat Shogun.
Yeah.
You know,
he,
he made some calculations,
he made some adjust adjustments in his career,
but that,
that style that he like,
he learned how to be this wild reckless motherfucker because that was so
rewarding.
Exactly.
Now,
yeah.
And it's hard for an athlete sometimes to change their natural instinct,
I think.
And you see that in the gym where an athlete,
either they're very tentative and calculating when they first get into the gym
and they kind of have to bring out that monster a little bit,
learn to be a finisher and they tend to look a little bit boring and maybe like
an underachiever where you get a guy like forest or leaving that goes out there
and they just go balls to the wall throwing big shots and sometimes they get
knocked out and sometimes they get their hand raised and the,
you have to walk that fine line and you know,
unfortunately they're playing with their brains,
you know,
they're putting all of their going all in,
every,
every fight they're going all in and they don't know how they're going to walk
out of it.
Um,
so it's really interesting.
It's interesting to see how far the sport's evolved.
I mean,
every couple of years is sport evolves to a brand new level.
You see these young kids coming in now that are better equipped and better
skilled than the champions of 10 years ago.
Glenn,
they're not even contenders.
Yeah.
They're not even outside the top 20.
Right?
Yeah.
There's guys that are just coming up that are 21 years old that have a better
skillset than world champions of 10 years ago.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Insanity.
It is amazing.
Um,
one of the issues when it comes to weight cutting and rehydration or dehydration
rather is head trauma.
Yeah.
And it's one of the reasons why rehydrating with an IV is so critical because if
you look at boxing,
the majority of the instances of men suffering,
uh,
in fight brain damage,
Gerald Mcclellan,
Duk Koo,
Kim,
like there's a lot of these cases in almost all of them involves someone weight
cutting.
Yup.
And because of that boxing and now MMA has adjusted schedule where the fighters
way in the day before where they used to weigh in the day of the match,
old school boxing matches,
you would see them way in the day of the match,
they,
and they would still cut weight and then they would try to rehydrate and they
didn't know what the fuck they were doing back then.
And guys had dry brains.
I mean,
literally.
Yep.
And because of that,
made them more susceptible to cerebral hemorrhages and brain damage and all
sorts of different things.
Uh,
very few heavyweight fighters suffered from brain in,
in an actual fight.
It was usually,
you know,
years and years of repeated head trauma that got them,
but not like one event,
like a general McClellan event.
Sure.
And,
uh,
for folks who don't know,
Gerald McClellan was,
he was one of the great light heavyweights of,
uh,
while he was a,
he was a light heavyweight and he was a super middleweight as well.
It was,
um,
and he was one of the guys who was eventually gonna fight.
Roy Jones Jr fought Nigel Benn in,
uh,
you know,
an epic contest had been really badly hurt.
They collided heads,
uh,
and he was all fucked up and he went back to his corner and he took a knee and
wound up bowing out of the fight and then immediately went into a coma.
And,
uh,
had some horrible,
horrible brain injuries because of that.
And that was a fight that,
uh,
changed a lot of people's ideas about a weight cutting and about the dangers of
head trauma.
Because before that fight,
Gerald Mcclellan was taught to be like an invincible destroyer.
I mean,
people had seen him,
he was just knocking everybody out.
He was one of the crunk stars,
Cronk boxing being a manual Stuart's team that produced Tommy Hearns.
And you know,
so many great,
great fighters came out of that gym and they all were just assassins.
And he was one of the best.
Gerald McClellan was a fucking vicious,
vicious killer.
And,
uh,
everybody had to wash that.
And,
uh,
you know,
and he's still alive to this day.
He's blind and he's all fucked up and sad shit directly related to dehydration,
right?
Yeah.
Hydration.
I would say so.
I mean,
it certainly contributed,
right?
It,
it assisted in the,
uh,
the damage and that's something that I pound,
you know,
my,
my soapbox when I talk to athletes when I talked to anybody is about help you
gotta be healthy.
If you're not healthy,
you can't perform.
You can't compete.
If your body is healthy,
then you can do absolutely anything.
It'll do anything you ask of it.
If you maintain its health for a long period of time,
not just fight week,
not just start eating organic and green fight week.
When you start cutting weight or two or three weeks beforehand,
it has to be before training camp even starts.
You have to be eating a lot of food,
the proper food at the right times consistently get your body weight down to a,
you know,
a,
your body mass down to a solid ratio.
Somewhere around that 10% range.
If you're a male mixed martial arts for females,
anywhere between 18 20%,
let's say
dip below 10% is that dangerous?
It's not,
but that's really for competition time because like with,
with lance and all my,
all my male athletes,
I try and keep them right around 10% the bigger guys,
maybe we get a little closer to the 12% the littler guys,
a leaner guys maybe you know between eight and 10 but right around 10 is the
sweet spot.
So we keep them around 10 that means they have weight to work off because they
need that for the first few phases.
When I work with training camps and such,
we break the training camp down in the multiple three week phases so we can
actually go through the proper training protocols and then peak towards the very
end.
So we can deal with the rigors of the training,
the bumps,
the bruises,
the bangs of slams.
We have the extra body fat to kind of insulate us so we can keep our joints and
ligaments strong and pliable.
Um,
so body extra body fat actually does that.
It does,
absolutely it does.
It's just another layer of insulation when you're constantly grinding on guys
and being,
you know,
wrenched against the wall and picked up and slammed,
50 times because you're drilling,
whatever move you need,
that little bit of insulation,
the leaner you get,
the dryer your joints get,
the more susceptible to injury you become.
So is that a scientific fact,
like your joints get dryer when you're leaner,
when you're leaner?
Absolutely.
Huh.
How does that work?
I mean,
is there a fat in between your joints?
I'm not gonna I don't think I can speak intelligently enough to break down the
true science of it,
but it's something that certainly remains a,
I know when I was a power lifter we would increase our body fat in order to
increase the leverage points within our joints.
So you can have,
um,
you know,
when I was a a power lift out and intentionally increase my body fat to like,
15,
18% and my numbers would absolutely go through the roof.
I would get less joint pain,
less injuries.
So call it,
you know,
bro Science,
if some people like to throw that term around there,
but you just feel better,
feel stronger and the leaner you get specifically when you start heading into
the peaking phase,
which is now mild dehydration,
as we get closer to fight week sets in,
the entire body becomes drier.
So there's less,
less tricity within the muscles.
You're more susceptible to those,
um,
injuries,
overuse injuries and such.
Bro,
science is a very tricky word,
right?
It's,
yeah,
absolutely.
It's fucking,
it's,
it's very limiting.
Like they hit you with that bro Science and they gotcha as if it's an
accusation,
but I don't,
it's almost a,
it means experience unless you're just throwing shit at the wall.
But there's a lot of throwing shit at the wall too.
I think more,
more than the experience.
You know,
there's certain like things that you would say maybe would be bro Science that
turned out to be like legit,
like,
um,
things along the line.
It's like we want to talk about experience,
things like ancient training methods that have turned out to be the right way to
do it.
Like all those old school rocky methods and everyone rocky was training in
Siberia and he was running through the snow and dragging logs.
A lot of times people would,
if it wasn't for all the data that we have now,
people would consider that kind of bro Science cause that's like,
you know,
oh you don't fucking have to chop logs.
You'd dummy.
Actually,
it's a really good way to exercise.
So literally,
you know,
but for the longest time most people thought no,
you had to use a nautilus machine and you had a fucking do everything.
Dre Go with the fucking heart monitors and all that stuff.
That computers hooked up to him.
But Bro,
science is a nice way.
They can shut you down and make you look stupid.
I know.
It's fucking pisses me off because I get this shit all the time.
You know,
everyone's always growling.
You're a bro.
I'm a bro.
And even a bro,
like you could call someone a bro and you limit there any,
anything that they have to say?
Anything they have to say about culture or anything they have to say about
society?
Any opinions,
any thoughts,
any philosophies they might have.
You're a bro Bro.
And that's,
I will wear that proudly,
but it's,
we're evidence based so we can say evidence-based Bro Science that,
you know,
don't do anything unless
it's been proven.
If we have a concept or an idea.
And I,
you know,
obviously in my office I have a team that works with me,
so it's not just me and the black and gold shirt running around.
I have a team,
I've,
you know,
employees that have um,
degrees,
masters in exercise physiology.
I've registered dieticians on staff,
so it's a complete team within the dolce diet that puts this information out
there and looks after the athletes.
So it's not just me running around with my stop watching my clipboard handed
people bottles of water.
So it truly is a scientific process,
but it's also based upon the experience.
And I've been doing this for 25 years,
you know,
since shit 93 professionally getting paid to do this.
And I have tremendous amounts of data.
I have almost all the data I've ever had collected on athletes and students and
clients that I've worked with.
Anecdotal data as well.
Athletes telling you how good they feel good after,
what did they,
it makes them feel bad.
Yep.
What did they eat today?
What did they waited?
They were their bowel movements.
What was the training systems like?
When did they get sick?
What's your sense of humor like?
I mean I speak with the wives.
I speak with the husbands,
I speak with the coaches.
I speak with the training partners.
I know everything about the athlete,
the time they wake up,
the time they have that bowel movement,
all the way through the day.
I know the intensity of the training and of the volume and the training under
the amount of rounds that they put in.
I know there,
you know,
caloric breakdown.
I know their lean mass ratios.
Oftentimes I know what their blood work looks like.
We have a lot of data and based upon this data is how we come up with our
methodology and how we continue to evolve.
Because every time,
I mean it's like every week you see me at the UFC is quite often,
well that's not just,
I'm not sure throwing shit at the wall.
I'm taking what I did on Friday,
Saturday of that weekend.
On Sunday,
I'm looking at the numbers and I'm retooling it because Monday I'm going to
another fight week somewhere and we're continuing to evolve this process as we
move forward.
So we,
it,
it's,
it's evidence based scientific principles that's also battle tested and proven
viable with experience because there's a lot of science out there that,
you know,
the,
the guys in the suits in the lab coats,
they're going to point to and say that's the way they do it.
But they've never actually done it in the human element.
They've never actually seen it work.
They just sit in the classroom and they talk about it and they pontificate on
it.
But it's never truly been proven in the real world.
And that's what we do also.
So we have the benefit of that.
Plus we have the benefit of all the scientific evidence.
That's that that's out there also.
And that's kind of what we wrote roll into this also
makes and MMA are so much higher than the stakes in any other sport when it
comes to proven concepts in the real world in quotes,
because the real world and MMA you're,
you're fucking consciousness is on the line.
Your health isn't the line.
Your body is getting get hit by things that would ordinarily,
like if you were in uh,
any sort of a real life situation and someone kicked you in the head,
that person would go to jail.
Meanwhile,
in this scenario they're rewarded for being able to kick you in the head.
They got a bonus,
they get a fucking bed jet bonus.
Yeah,
they get a k o the night when that's its performance of the night now.
But um,
do you think,
and this is a really touchy subject,
but I think it's an important one to bring up.
Do you think that a lot our ideas about what's physically possible when it comes
to training and when it comes to fighting are distorted because of performance
enhancing drugs?
Absolutely.
I think performance enhancing drugs,
drugs have set the bar in all sports,
in,
in a culture,
whether it's looking at the movies,
looking at the magazine,
cover,
track and field track and field everywhere.
Golf,
Nascar,
anywhere you look that there's money on the line where you get rewarded for
performance.
There's some sort of ancillary,
you know,
good or you know,
commodity being used or purchased or consumed to improve your performance
specific.
It's very evident in the world of mixed martial arts because these guys and
girls are getting punched and kicked in the head in there losing consciousness
and they're breaking bones and getting limbs torn off.
So now you have these advanced superhumans out.
They're able to,
you know,
rip joints and,
and punch brains and do all these other things.
So it,
it does,
I think the odds are much greater,
you know,
for the risk is certainly much greater for anybody who competes.
Yeah.
That's where I took exception to a lot of people saying like,
who cares if someone juices,
you know,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm gonna kick their ass anyway.
You're like,
Chris Weidman said that about Vito Belfort and I appreciate the fact that he
thinks that way cause he's a champion and that's how the champion feels.
Yeah.
But the reality is there are punches that can be landed when you are on EPO and
test and Jack to the fucking gills and whatever the fuck else you're doing that
you wouldn't have the energy to land in a normal scenario.
Like it's very rare that a guy can do like what Tj Dillashaw does and go balls
to the walls for five fucking rounds.
Yeah.
Tj can do it as a natural athlete because he's got a fucking tireless work
ethic.
He's unbelievably dedicated and focused and he's 145 pounds.
Yeah.
That's another big factor.
Huge.
The difference between that and a guy like Overeem.
Yeah.
Who Alster Overeem came into the UFC against Brock Lesnar.
He was two 65 shredded to the tits,
looked like a fucking superhero out of a comic book.
Pissed hot and has never been the same guy again.
Yeah.
And that's the reality is now he's being tested.
He shrunk,
he'd lost body mass.
Is it just seems to affect a guy's chin as well.
The the,
the thing about taking performance enhancing drugs is it,
it doesn't just seem to affect your cardio,
but it seems to also affect your ability to take a shot.
Yeah,
we saw that in Mark Hunt versus big foot,
big foot Silva and Mark Hunt had one of the greatest heavyweight fights ever as
far as like from a fan's perspective,
like watching an entertaining fight.
What a fucking war.
These guys went to a war and big foot absorbed everything that Mark Hunt hit him
with one of the greatest knockout artists in the history of kickboxing and MMA.
Hey,
mark Hunt's awesome.
He's a monster.
Big Foot absorbed it.
They tested them after the fight and he apparently he tested before the fight.
Thought that was it.
I don't have to worry about this anymore.
And they jacked him with a fucking giant hit.
Like they took a fucking big gulp full of test and just shoved it right in his
ass.
He was just fucking just completely juiced up when he fought his,
his levels were through the roof after the fight.
And because of that he was able to absorb.
I mean I'm speculating as to why he was able to absorb those shots,
but I've got to think that it has something to do with it.
It definitely increases aggression.
It increases tenacity.
It brings out that killer instinct and maybe an athlete in that state,
they can walk through punches more because they have more of that primal urge
and instinct and those elevated hormones pumping through their body because
that's really what testosterone does and God knows what else is out there.
I mean,
I don't even think we're aware in this room of all the drugs and performance
enhancers that are truly out there and these,
you know,
evil geniuses around the world are creating and sticking into the athletes and
putting them back out there to see what the effect is.
No big foot got popped on a simple urine test,
which is quite fascinating because the UFC has taken a lot of flack about their
stance on performance enhancing drugs and people like,
oh,
it's just lip service.
UFC doesn't give a shit.
This is how much the UFC gives a shit.
They've tested all of their best athletes with blood tests in a way that is
fucked up.
A lot of performances,
like they've stepped in and it costs more than $40,000 every time they do this.
So every single athletes,
they're doing this outside of the jurisdiction of the athletic commissions.
So the athletic commissions has their own specific protocol for how they
testified her.
Then the UFC steps in and brings in like the,
the highest,
most stringent Olympic testing that they can find.
You know,
they bring in the best guys that not only that they have a chain of command,
they have a chain of evidence rather of um,
uh,
possession where like say if you have Mike Dolce comes to the gym and you test
Jamie,
you fucking carry that shit on a plane to wherever the lab is.
Like you have it in your possession.
It never leaves you.
When you take a shit,
that fucking suitcase sits right in front of you.
Nobody can come into your hotel room,
grab it.
No,
it goes directly from your hands to the lab.
They ha they are very,
very,
very specific about that.
The reason being is because there's no shenanigans with these blood tests.
And because of that,
a guy like Chael Sonnen got popped for EPO,
elevated levels of test,
human growth hormone,
all this,
I mean he's got,
he's been popped for a bunch of different things.
Actually the elevated test was the urine thing,
but when they got him with the blood,
they found him with all,
they've got him with some anti,
uh,
there's some thing that they use for fertility.
They hit,
he was,
uh,
he was on Clomid,
which is what you,
uh,
you take when they take you off of human growth hormone or testosterone to try
to restart your body system.
It's,
everyone's a fucking chemical factory.
It's crazy.
It's not everyone,
obviously it's some,
it's some,
and I think it's a smaller percentage than a lot of the articles and interviews
come out with,
you know,
a lot of athletes out.
There's 90% of the guys who are 50%.
That's what he,
one of his famous statements after he got caught,
he's like,
everyone's using in camp.
Everyone.
It depends on which camp is talking about,
you know,
cause there's,
I know that there's,
there's a ton of great athletes out there.
Ronda Rousey's,
one of them,
you know,
lifelong drug free athlete,
Johny Hendricks,
he's one of them.
Nick Lens is one of the Penn.
Bj Penn is one of them.
Um,
there's John Fitch,
John Fitch is one of them.
So there's a,
there's a lot of them,
huge list of top tier athletes that are clean and lifelong clean and we have no
reason to suspect otherwise.
Right.
And they beat the piss out of a lot of the ped users.
But you know,
to the guys and girls that are using these,
maybe they wouldn't be a top five,
top 10,
top 20 even.
Maybe they wouldn't even make an interview view.
See if not for some sort of enhancement.
I would love to go back to pride.
The pride days.
I'm a huge pride fans or don't get me wrong,
some of my greatest moments as a fan,
as an MMA fan,
absolutely.
Watching the,
just the best fights of pride fade or versus Cro cop.
Well,
he's just absorbing every shot cro cop hits him with and plowing forward and
blasting him fade or beat cro cop in a fucking kickboxing about.
So a lot of people don't realize.
And fader was the first guy that ever made me want to be fat.
He make that sexy,
didn't it?
Bald bastard beat the fuck out of everybody with this floppy gut.
Yup.
You know,
and I'm like this motherfucker,
he was kicking everybody's ass and he looks like he looks like he just stepped
out of his fucking station wagon and waddled onto the beach,
you know,
to play volleyball with some friends.
He always,
he was much bigger actually early in his career.
And then as he got older,
he lost a lot of body mass,
a lot of muscle mass.
But man,
I would love to see what those guys were actually doing.
And in pride,
I mean that's almost,
it's almost a gentleman's agreement that you're agreeing to compete on drugs
because that was in the contracts.
You know,
when we saw that pretty recently,
and I had known some guys back in the day that it said that's in the contract
and like,
are you fucking kidding me?
What?
Ensign came on the podcast and he read it off to us and sanity.
But in that case,
if you're going to sign that contract and then you're loaded up to the gills,
I'm not going to sit here and judge morally because you're agreeing to those
rules.
Right.
It's like kicks to the face on the ground.
Okay.
If you're going to agree to it,
you know,
but in the UFC here where there's unified rules,
it's a whole nother bar ballgame.
Well,
when Jason Chambers was a trainee,
a 10th planet,
he went over,
he was fighting in Japan.
I won't even say the organization,
but they wanted him to fight at one 85 and Jason's like,
I walk around like one 70 like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like I want to fight one 55 no,
no,
no.
You're going to get on steroid much legit.
Oh Wow.
They wanted him to get on roids.
They literally told him to get on roids league,
Japanese legal over there.
I mean,
is that just culturally it's not an issue?
I don't think they give a fuck about that.
They just looked at him,
you know Jason's a handsome bastard
and they sell like this fucking beautiful bastard.
We need some muscles on this motherfucker to sell,
sell,
sell south.
No,
you can't have a guy looking like nick Diaz kicking everybody's ass with a
normal athlete looking body.
You want to Kevin Randleman looking fucking Jason Chambers with Kevin Randleman,
his muscles.
Jesus Christ.
How much could we sell that Dan put that guy on a fucking cover,
put up,
put a banana.
Whereas Dick is stuffing in his underwear.
So we an athletes super.
Yeah,
but they literally told him,
I mean from his voice to my ears,
they told him and we were friends.
We still are friends.
He,
they told him to do steroids.
Oh Shit.
So they do,
I mean,
and there was always speculation.
Like we would look at Vandelay and we'd go,
how,
how do you,
how have you built like that?
How was that?
How can a guy be built like that and go to war for 10 minutes at 10 minute round
and just never get tired?
Like how is that possible?
It's not right.
It's
very rare.
Those are the outliers that are able to look like that and compete like that.
And I spent some time with Brian Stan and he just telling story about how when
he went to Japan and flaws it Japan or China and fought Manderlay and he's like,
I'm flying on a flight.
I'm sucked out,
I'm dehydrated,
I'm cutting weight.
And I show up and I see Vander Lee and he is just fucking jacked and veiny and
like smiling and just spit and piss and vinegar.
And he's like,
that's when I knew,
I knew he was fucking gassed up and you know,
and then you'd go out there and the fight goes how it is.
And it was,
they got fight performance in the knife,
fight of the night,
whatever,
you know.
And Vandelay had a very good chin on that night because Stan draw,
you know,
hit him with big shots and back and forth that went and unfortunately Stan was
the the guy to fall down first.
Yeah,
it is that thing your,
your ability to absorb punishment actually changes depending upon what your on
it seems to be.
It seems to be,
I mean we're,
we're talking,
we're kind of speculating.
Obviously we don't have the evidence in front of us.
So science.
Yeah,
we're bro Science and shit.
Spit stand reasonably accused Kung Lee of being on performance enhancing drugs
after he fought Michael Bisping.
Yeah.
And that's,
you don't no evidence,
no evidence other than a photo.
But that photo was pretty fucking interesting.
It,
well it's interesting because kingly was,
is 40 but you know,
in Congress defense he said that he had had a series of aggravating injuries and
this was the first camp where he had had surgeries,
had fixed up all those injuries and he went on a pretty rigorous strength and
conditioning regime shore for that,
for that training camp.
Like,
you can't definitely say that he was on something and he didn't test piss hot
and that's it.
So I mean,
I don't know,
and it's,
it's a tough call because then we're just kind of being haters like,
Oh yeah dude,
he looks fucking great at 40 and like,
well I don't look that good.
So he must be on juice and there's that human element to it.
But if he doesn't piss hot,
I mean,
how can we accuse and blame,
you know him of doing something wrong when he didn't and it didn't affect his
performance in a positive manner anyway because it's being went out there
and beat his ass,
beat his ass.
Damn Bisbing look good enough.
Fight.
That was fucking awesome.
Version of Bisping we've ever seen.
Bisping's a tenacious motherfucker.
He's a mean motherfucker.
He's just tenacious and Shit,
man.
He's just still in the mix still,
you know,
still believing that one day he's going to be the champion.
I was just going to keep fucking chipping away.
He gets beat,
he comes back,
you know,
and to,
in his defense,
everyone that's beaten him as essentially been popped for steroids.
Yeah.
Dan Henderson who knocked him out,
wasn't popped for steroids,
but he was on a legal version of testosterone replacement therapy before they
outlawed that stuff,
which I think is a good thing to outlaw it.
And this is coming from a person who takes testosterone.
I'm a,
I'm 47 years old.
I take testosterone every week.
I take,
uh,
sh I used to take a cream.
Now I took a shot.
It seems to last longer.
It seems to work better.
But why do I do it?
First of all,
because I'm not competing against anybody and it makes me feel better.
Um,
it worked.
My body works better when I take it mean that's what testosterone replacement is
all about.
But when it comes to professional athletes doing it,
man,
it's very tricky because on one side,
an athlete can take it and it can make them feel better and they can perform
better when their career would be over.
Like you take a guy like a Roger Clemens,
and I don't know whether or not Roger Clemens doing anything,
but most people believe he did.
And he's a baseball player.
And then deep into his forties all of a sudden the mother fuckers,
he's still throwing 95 mile an hour fast balls and he looks fantastic.
He's built like a brick shit house.
What's going on there?
And we'll most likely he got on hormone replacement.
So the idea being that when you're getting older,
you're getting wiser and you have accumulated all this experience and all this
knowledge,
but your body does not perform the way it did when you were younger.
It just doesn't,
the hormones,
they go away.
Your body is preparing for death.
I mean,
essentially that's what's going on.
But it isn't bullshit because it's kind of the way the world works.
You know what I mean?
We were only here for a short amount of time,
otherwise fucking Aristotle be sitting right there.
You know,
he'd still be around,
but you know,
I'm on this show.
It would probably be a boring passengers.
I don't understand his language either.
Yeah,
no,
I'd love to hear.
I'm just kidding.
But you know,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like everyone has their time and when your time,
this is obviously hypocritical coming from me because I just admitted that I did
take testosterone,
but when you're a fighter,
there's,
there's the guys that they've gone through all this experience.
Their bodies started to fade off and then they get on it and then boom,
all of a sudden their world beaters.
The best example is Vituro.
Yeah,
right.
Vito Belfort,
I maintain that TRT v tour was one of the most spectacular fighters in the
history of fighting his knock out of Rukh lock.
Luke Rockhold,
his knockout of Bisbing.
I mean his knockout of Dan Henderson.
I mean,
he was a fucking destroyer when he was on test.
Yeah.
He would show up with muscles on his fucking eyebrows.
I mean,
literally he had muscles on his gums.
His whole body looks like a muscle.
It was insane and he was so aggressive and so confident.
It was a completely different vetoer than the Vito that fought like Sakuraba
when he fought in pride,
which was a decade earlier.
Yeah.
I mean it's crazy to see something like that happen.
And on one hand,
one hand,
I love it.
And one hand I want to see Vituro fight like that.
I want to see a destroyer.
I'm a guy walks watching entertaining fights.
I like watching spectacular performances.
But on another hand I want to see,
I want to see someone fighting someone where it's just will and determination
and discipline and focus and you,
you,
you work towards something and then you achieve it and you do it just by hard
work.
Sure.
I don't want it to be a Goddamn pharmacy competition.
Yeah.
You know,
and that's high level sports.
It is quite that and kind of a moral conversation.
Let's,
let's skew this a little bit.
So you look at like stem cell research now,
is that a performance enhancer?
Yeah.
It's going to be reattaching an ACL from somebody else's ad,
a performance enhancer.
Sure.
It can be right.
I mean,
well it certainly can fix a bad body and that will enhance the performance of
that person can be.
It's an interesting,
and I've heard [inaudible] say this before and I'm not defending,
I'm just say that.
Yeah.
Yes.
I don't know if he's performance enhancing that.
I think he was making a reference to Weidman who had gone over to Germany I
believe,
and had some sort of Regena keen.
I don't know.
Well I've had that he's wrong and it comes to that doesn't enhance your
performance.
It just makes your inflammation go down.
Okay.
I mean Weidman has mangled knees.
I mean he's had arthritis in his knees so bad that he can't even get his foot to
touches.
But like lift his head.
He looked like this like I'm doing sitting right here.
He can't,
he can't do that.
He couldn't get his heel to touch his ass.
His knees are so arthritic and yet he's still beat Anderson Silva twice like
that with those knees.
Cause he's a fucking monster.
He's a monster.
He's not even 30 oh yeah,
he's a monster.
But what he did was not,
it's not going to make him like me.
It'll make his knees work better,
but that just,
there'd be like normal knees.
It's not like he's going to get to a point where he has like,
you know,
like when you saw Vic tours muscles,
that shit wasn't normal.
So that was above average.
Yeah.
Like an average 16 year old kid who works out,
you know,
once or twice a week has better knees than the middle weight champion of the
world.
That's the point is it's the actual pliability of his joints itself.
I mean,
does that increase some mechanical advantage when the knees work better?
Yeah,
but it only makes it like a normal person.
It's not like,
you know what you can get if you're tested up to the gills.
So I don't see how you can make that comparison.
Yeah.
Aesthetically.
And where is the,
where's the line on medical intervention to performance enhancement or
supplementation?
Supplementation is a good one because that's,
yeah,
creatine.
Well,
I remember beach and that simple.
Bj was shitting on.
Um,
and I'm a huge Bj Penn Fan will be to the day I die.
But BJ was shitting all over GSP,
you know,
hey,
you're taking a test.
You know,
he'd taken Gh,
tell the truth what's going on.
And then while you watch BJ working out and he had a fucking,
he had a counter filled with these different supplements.
There's a bunch of shit that they would give him after every,
uh,
every meal.
It was all legal.
It was all like,
you know,
glutamine and things along those lines and,
fish oil and all these different,
various supplements.
But those various supplements,
it's,
that's not food,
that's food that has been broken down and they've isolated very specific
components that they've shown to enhance performance.
So you're taking performance enhancing supplements when your taking anything.
I mean,
any,
the reason why you take multimineral and multivitamins is you want to enhance
the performance of your body,
period.
I mean,
that,
that is what's going on.
It's just going on it,
uh,
an edge level as opposed to a jump.
Like when you're tested up,
like [inaudible] tested,
they caught him before.
This is what made them cancel.
Um,
testosterone replacement in Nevada.
I mean they had already had issues with it but they started testing guys off you
like just randomly like come here like pee in that cup would hook.
That's how they got Overeem.
Vito tested an average person.
It's like an average males because of 300 to 800 is like a high level.
V was 1,475 man,
that's insane.
It doesn't exist in nature.
It just doesn't exist in nature.
And that was one of the reasons why they were like,
ah,
okay.
And this is not idle speculation coming from me.
By the way,
this is me talking to people that are in the know people that were actually
there.
The whole conversation that went down,
I was privy to a lodge and it was very tricky because they,
you have to find out what,
what's ethical.
I mean they loud it in the first place because doctors were saying,
my client has low testosterone and he has an issue Gonad ism or whatever.
Hypergonadism whatever the issue is.
My client has low testosterone.
Um,
I as a doctor believe that he has a medical issue that needs to be addressed.
We're going to supplement his testosterone.
So the athletic commissions allowed this,
but they didn't totally understand what they were allowing because they didn't
know that you could take testosterone.
And if you took testosterone and then got off testosterone,
you're let natural levels crash.
So then you show up at the doctor and you say,
hey man,
test me.
I feel pretty weak and that the doctor says you have low testosterone,
I'm going to write you a prescription for testosterone.
Then you bring that to the athletic commission.
My doctors,
uh,
allowed me to take testosterone.
Here's my blood work.
And they go,
all right,
it seems pretty good.
Go ahead and take it.
I mean,
that what was going on?
That's what happened with Nate Marquardt.
That's what happened with a lot of people.
Um,
that was the issue with,
uh,
when Nate Marquardt was pulled out of his fight with Rick Story.
The very last minute is because the Pennsylvania Athletic Commission tested him
and he was jacked through the roof and they were like,
what you do you are you doing is dangerous.
What was his number?
Do you remember?
I don't remember so I won't say it but it was [inaudible].
It was astronomical and it was very high.
It was not a number that exists in nature and that's the issue is that these
guys were same as mark Hon.
It was not a number that exists in nature that these guys were taking hyper
levels of testosterone when they give you testosterone unless you are going to
the doctor and that doctor is the only one who administers testosterone and they
do it right in front of you.
You can,
you could put in as much in as you want.
Sure.
You know,
if,
if Mike Dolce gets a prescription for testosterone and you go to your doctor,
your doctor's going to give you a fucking month supply and you could say,
I don't want to put the whole month and right now see what so look out and then
he just fucking running through walls.
Like the thing from the fantastic four is it's,
it's very weird.
You know,
it's,
it's very,
I mean like if you're on anything else,
if you are on any other kind of medication,
they'll give you,
you know,
you take two pills in the morning,
you take two pills at night and here's,
here's your pills,
take those pills.
Yup.
But you could just decide to throw the whole bottle down your throat if you're
fucking nuts.
Like the only way you could prevent that with testosterone is by restricting
access and making that access only through that medical provider that does it.
You know?
Right.
There were no,
everyone knows.
And so they decided to just stop the testosterone replacement.
There was no way they could regulate it.
There's too many ethical concerns.
There's too many concerns with,
but the thing is they started it and they let these people get on it and then
they got him off of it.
And when you get people off of it,
their whole endocrine system just crashes and there was no transition period.
None.
Yeah.
You need a long transition period.
Like this v Tour Weidman fight is going to be spectacularly interesting from
that perspective because vittores previous performances have been some of the
best performances I've ever seen in all my years of watching MMA.
He just looked fantastic and if there was no concern whatsoever,
if uh,
there was no issue with testosterone,
he wasn't on anything.
He was just fucking training like a wild man and putting in,
you know,
if he was younger and this was all going on,
if he didn't have like a noticeable dip and rise and change of his body anatomy,
he would be like one of the most heralded contenders ever.
But everybody looks at him sideways.
Even to this day.
Like Weidman is a huge favorite coming into this fight.
I mean,
I don't know what the numbers are,
but I remember the last time I looked at it was it was a pretty heavy favorite.
Maybe you can look it up,
Jamie.
Find out what Chris Weidman over Vito Belfort is.
If you look at how v toward destroyed Dan Henderson,
you could have destroyed Luke Rockhold.
You look at how he destroyed Bisbing.
Who would say,
how could anybody be a favorite over this guy?
And the
reason is is because the testosterone,
sure it's 100% no one wants to bring it up.
I mean the UFC,
he's probably upset that I'm talking about it right now.
You know,
cause they don't like bringing it up.
Like when I do those countdown shows,
we don't talk about testosterone.
I would like to,
I would like to talk about it.
I would like to bring in experts.
I would like to,
I would like to talk to a guy like you.
I'd like to talk to an endocrinologist.
I'd like to say what up,
what up?
What is the recovery process?
Cow.
Can a man bring his natural levels back up to where v tour was,
you know,
is it possible that's going to be difficult,
not knowing what his blood work or how bad off he was.
You know,
going into the TRT program,
he's going to come out worse off when he said he was at 180 that was what he
said,
which is really low and I would believe that no one,
a lot of the Brazilians,
a lot of those kids get on in their early teens because it's a social medicine
over there.
You walk into a gym and that's what the coach hands them,
and I heard this story from dozens of of Brazilians and it's nothing against the
culture.
It's just something that's normal.
Well,
it's legal,
it's legal.
It's like walking into a GNC and get some protein powder.
It's not like it is over here.
What's over here?
You've got a bit,
get your,
you know,
if you're going to go to a gym and become a bodybuilder and you want to get
testosterone or steroids,
you're going to have to do dealings with some shady people.
Brazil,
you go to the pharmacy,
you go in and you get it done properly.
But unfortunately you open up four to one.
That's almost five to one,
five to one that's big over veto.
The veto that destroyed Dan Henderson the first round,
the veto,
that wheel kick Luke Rockhold into oblivion and someone's a five to one favorite
over him.
That's incredible.
And that's because of that.
It's amazing.
Everyone Remembers Vito when he fought Randy when he was 240 pounds and it looks
like a lion.
Absolutely.
And those are the days I think that if caught up with him and yeah,
cause the issue,
well that was back when he was training with,
uh,
his,
his friend Curtis,
who was as a bodybuilder friend who's dead now,
guy died from,
from steroids.
That's right.
I remember that.
We used to call them garden hoses because,
uh,
we would,
work out with this guy who'd be at the gym and he had garden hoses for veins.
I mean,
he would stand there like this and they were just garden hoses all over his
body.
He was so big,
he was so big.
You couldn't believe that he was a human being.
It's a guy's like that from the nineties error bodybuilding days.
They're all fucking dying now.
Yeah,
I've been seeing that.
Mike Matarazzo just died.
Yeah,
crazy Nasser,
that big circle,
somebody,
he's dead.
He died.
Those guys were just just red lining the body and red lining.
The capabilities when the sports,
so we think of bodybuilding like the golden era is like the Arnold
Schwarzenegger,
the Franco Columbia,
the pumping iron days and the body's didn't change that much.
Seventies to eighties they were kind of similar and then the early nineties
that's when Dorian Yates came and just exploded on the scene.
Then Ronnie Coleman followed up in these 260 pound mass monsters.
Five six,
five,
six fucking insanely crazy rip,
3% body fat garden
hoses running everywhere and it's wasn't as much from what I understand.
I've been working on a mass building strength building book now,
so I've been researching more of the bodybuilding side and I'm coming across all
this information where they're talking now about it.
It was like insulin and IGF one and growth hormone.
When those things came into play in those early nineties that's when the body's
changed.
But now you see what's happening.
1520 years later,
these guys in their forties and fifties are dropping dead of terrible,
terrible conditions almost directly with that,
where you see guys like Arnold and Franco,
you know,
still walking around,
knocking on the door of seventies Arnold's back on the spike.
She knows muscles.
He's pretty fucking big.
That Hollywood money,
man.
Come on man.
Right.
Media took care of everything I have to get.
There you go.
Yeah,
he,
but he is,
but you know,
Dorian in all fairness is fine too right now.
Yeah,
right now.
You know,
and that's the thing.
And He seems like a smarter guy.
Just knowing a little bit.
Actually when we were in Birmingham,
I swung by temple gym and get a chance to meet him.
What his historic,
you know,
to meet that guy.
Fucking crazy.
But we'll see.
And hopefully,
you know,
you don't want to see anything bad happen,
anybody,
but it's,
you know,
those guys are like on death watch to a degree.
What,
um,
what fails when they do that?
What fails in their body.
All these guys,
it seems to be heart related.
Their hearts are just exploding on them.
They're enlarged for starters,
and then they're just some sort of shut down,
break down and they're just exploding for lack of a more technical term.
But it's almost all cardiac related.
Like that's what Matarazzo he was waiting for a heart transplant.
Oh,
it wasn't even 50 years old yet.
Wow.
You know,
and he's,
he's a Boston Guy,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I remember when I was just a kid at that time and that's,
I was a fallen when I was watching these guys,
like,
you know,
that's what I want it to be.
And I was like,
well maybe a couple of them.
So now you've take steroids.
But like now he's,
these use a muscle tech and he's using the eas creatine and that's you.
I believe that both,
not never flex wheeler and flex had fucking kidney transplant.
He did it.
Yes.
I'm don't quote me on the kidney transplant,
but he had kidney failure and that's what took him out of bodybuilding at his
absolute prime.
I'm 90% sure was it is a transplant,
isn't that the kidney thing?
Due to cutting weight,
they would dehydrate the shit out of themselves.
Massive prescription diuretics.
So it's cutting weight is one thing.
Using a very powerful pharmaceutical diuretic that's like water and fucking,
you know,
I'm rubbing alcohol as far as you know,
putting that into your body.
And that's what like Mohammed,
Ben Aziza and I think Andrea is months or some of these famous older
bodybuilders were just huge into those prescription diuretics and they just
fucking blow their body up from the inside out,
look amazing on the outside.
And then guys like Paul the let you know,
I'm kind of really,
you know,
going back 20 years in my remembrance is a bodybuilding.
I remember these guys collapsing and just thinking like,
oh,
you know,
they didn't,
they look like such specimens.
Why are
they so unhealthy?
And that's really,
I think what turned me into what I am today.
I saw that,
you know,
and,
and take my story back even farther and I touched on it,
you know,
years ago where I saw my father collapse massive stroke.
I was eight year old kid and he was like really in shape.
He was a thoroughbred horse trainer and he just fucking had a massive stroke.
I was like,
how the fuck like spun,
how is this even possible?
And then all the doctor's visits and all this shit for years.
Well he was burning his candle at both ends.
Fucking drinking coffee in the morning,
not even until late at night,
working like 16,
20 hour days.
Really,
you know,
hard,
hard work and days,
you know,
sitting back,
kicking some beers and whatnot.
Burnt his body out from the inside family history of heart disease,
hypertension,
didn't take care of himself.
Boom.
Fast forward,
I see this,
this bodybuilding shit and it really fascinated nails fascinate as a,
as a boy all the way up through fascinated.
And as I continued and I was 280 pound power lifter at some point brought my
body,
we'd all the way up my mid twenties,
280 pounds.
And,
uh,
one day I go to the doctor for a basic health tests,
wellness test,
high cholesterol,
high blood pressure,
hypertension,
sleep apnea,
get hooked up to a holter monitor and heart palpitations doctors like,
what are you doing?
I'm like,
I don't fucking know.
I'm trying to be big on,
you know,
I tried to be Arnold Schwarzenegger over here.
And she's like,
yeah,
this got to change.
And that's when I,
my mind spun.
I just saw it for what it is.
I've pictured my father was like,
I got to fucking change this immediate.
And that's when I was performance science-based,
lots of supplements and lots of micronutrients and you know,
protein ratio and all that,
that bullshit,
that bodybuilding bullshit and then spun it.
And that's when I became this fucking organic like pseudo hippie health
longevity dude.
And when I focused on that and he lost 110 pounds,
you know,
through my own personal experience and what I was always working with athletes.
You know,
he like when I was,
since I was 17 years old for so my training business,
I was always working with athletes and I took that performance side and I went
to the longevity side.
And what I saw is once we all started focusing on longevity protocols as opposed
to performance protocols,
everybody's performance went through the roof,
their lean mass.
So when you say longevity protocols,
yeah.
What do you,
what do you mean specifically?
I mean,
I mean real food,
getting rid of all the supplements,
getting rid of all the pseudoscience,
getting back to what's most natural,
you know,
and I use the term earth grow nutrients because I used to say whole foods and
people thought that meant go shopping at the supermarket,
no eating food from the planet.
That was like really the first step for me.
And I don't care as much about micro nutrient ratios and Wayne,
cause I used to weigh my food and I used to sit there and I would spend a half
hour every night and program all my meals and come up with all these different,
you know,
training cycles and I was,
that do that.
It's insane dude about making these performance enhancements fast,
this fucking ridiculous sneak to focus on eating real food,
extremely nutrient dense foods from the planet's fresh as possible,
as live as possible.
And all the science that's out there shows that that's the healthier way.
And all these different cultures that eat like that tend to be much healthier,
perform at a higher level for a much longer period of time,
longer age,
you know,
a longer lifespan and a high utility.
And that's really the difference.
Not only do they live longer,
they have a very high utility while they're living longer,
50608090100 plus years old where they're still able to go out,
fish,
swim,
do all these different things.
That's what really turned my mind.
And this is back shit 15,
probably 15 years ago now.
Um,
and then I started implementing that with my athletes,
whether it's the power lifters,
the wrestlers of the grapplers,
and then your early two thousands and years was the NHB athletes before MMA.
That's like kind of how I got the start into,
uh,
you know,
the MMA world was through team Henzel,
Gracie on the east coast,
guys like Kurt Pellegrino and Dante Rivera when they're fighting for that ring
of combat,
you know,
Nhb,
titles and whatnot focused on,
you know,
those guys.
And it was all real foods and it was like everyone was like,
what do you mean I don't have to take my CytoSport,
my protein powder and pop all these fucking pills?
I was like,
no,
you know,
it was like almost like a leap of faith that for a while for a lot of athletes
to buy into.
Like,
you mean I have to eat salads and fruit and make a smoothie and just like,
you know,
now that we talk about in the culture is a little more advanced.
I think the science is out there and it's,
it's been proven for,
you know,
a decade plus that people realize,
well that's the better way to go now.
But going back,
you know,
10 15 years ago that was like everybody was living at a fucking jugs,
protein patters and GNCs and all that shit.
That was the big rage in the late nineties all the way into the early two
thousands and such.
So spun that,
switched it focused on the real foods and that's what we've been doing with the
athlete sense.
So going back to the longevity,
when I work with an athlete like a,
a Tiago,
that's her Rhonda Rousey or,
or whoever else,
my goal is not for them to win a world title.
My goal is not about their way into my goals,
not about really anything sport related within the next five years.
My goal is for them to be 120 years old,
healthy,
fresh,
vibrant,
showing their great,
great grandkids,
photos of back when they won the UFC world title and all these great times that
they have 120 years old.
Is that really pop?
Has that ever been done?
It's possible now if we focus on it now because we're talking,
that's 80 years from now and with the medical advancements that are happening
with the way science is continuing to evolve,
it's possible if we don't fuck it up early,
and this is where I talk to the athletes about the weight cutting Stuart's 52
weeks beforehand.
If we don't fuck everything up now,
science is going to advance to the point to keep us healthier,
longer offset some of these issues at a later stage of life.
Instead of having a like Matarazzo Nina fucking heart transplant when you're 40
instead of,
well maybe when you're 80 it's slowly starts to give out because you've eaten
fucking great,
highly nutrient dense foods your entire life.
You've been resting your body completely,
not burning your nervous system out.
You're training intelligently enough to stimulate progress but not enough to
shut anything down and break anything.
Now you're living a rewarding,
happy life surrounding yourself with positive people and that's something that
you talk about here all the time and that's almost the most important aspect is
being a very well adjusted,
happy,
positive individual.
And this is something that when I work with athletes,
a lot of people think that it's just this,
this fucking diet dude,
or I'm just making eggs for her hand in my athletes water.
I think that's the least of what I do.
The most of what I did was I try and get inside the athlete's head,
hadn't helped them focus on,
excuse me,
focus on their life and what they,
what they want out of their life,
setting up goals and helping them develop action steps in eliminating this
negative energy around them so they can truly realize their full potential.
And that's,
you know,
I call it,
we put a bubble of positivity around the athlete,
especially as we get closer to the competition because that's when it's most
important.
But it's really,
we try and keep that around them their entire life.
Give them the tools,
teach them the lessons now that they can carry on.
So we'll,
we all lift 120 I don't know,
but I've read scientific research that assumes or believes that there's humans
being born right now on the planet right now that will exceed 200 years old.
Now.
Will that happen?
Who fucking knows Jamie?
Look at him.
Don't make be.
Actually it could be he's fucked me as fuck.
He's gone.
Can I get more pussy?
Oh that.
Oh,
there you go.
Yeah.
Um,
but you,
you bring up some really important points about stress and about surrounding
yourself with positive things and positive energy.
You can tell the difference.
Like if you have some bad shit in your life,
you have some conflict,
you'll feel bad about that conflict you feel.
And the key is to resolve that stuff as much as possible.
And then,
you know,
figuring out a way to make peace with the rest of it and move on with your life.
And just the less you put out battling it,
the better you'll feel about it.
Yeah.
Just you know,
when I was younger I would argue to people that everything was constantly
involved in conflict.
And then I realized as I got older,
the less conflict I have,
the better I feel.
And the more I resolve conflict and not and not and not get in it,
it's better for everybody.
It's better for that person.
It's better for me this certain shit that's unavoidable.
But like all these people that are running around suing people all the time,
those are the mother fuckers die heart attack.
So those are the mother fuckers that have stress cause they're constantly
involved in battle and not the right kind of battle.
Either.
Not like a competition,
you know,
but just trying to lash out and then dealing with people lashing out at you and
all your day is spent thinking about it.
And if he says this,
I'm going to say that.
And then if she says that,
I'm going to tell her what the fuck is up.
And that kind of shit wears on you man.
You're grinding your gears all day,
eats you alive and people don't think of it.
Do you think you don't think of that as being a stress like they think of stress
as being bills.
They think of stress as being traffic,
no stresses.
Every,
all those things are stress,
relationships,
friendships,
work conflict.
When you're at work all day and you hate your job,
that stress,
that is stress that grinds on you.
That feeling like when you get out of work at the end of the day and you have
that weight lifted off your shoulders,
that means you're in a bad job.
You got to figure out a way where you don't have that.
If it's possible,
if it's possible,
find that way.
That was me 10 years ago was a municipal tax assessor,
the state of New Jersey.
Oh,
amazing.
It was the just saying all those things together make me want to fucking jump
off a roof on Friday.
I would literally get depressed on Friday because I knew Monday was coming.
Yeah,
I know that feeling and it was fucking,
it was God damn hell,
but I was making a shit load of money.
My mom was so proud of me.
I had the 401k in the six weeks off vacation.
I was living the American dream.
I fucking hated myself.
I sat around,
I remember this was the turning point for me.
I sat around a boardroom table and it was a lot younger than my closest peer.
And I'm looking at all these older dudes and we're all sitting there in suits
and like,
we all were so fucking important,
you know,
being those dickheads.
And they're all overweight.
They're all,
they all have red faces and they're all talking about how they're going to
fucking,
you know,
sneak off to the bar before they go home because they don't want to deal with
the fucking family and the kids and all the fucking bullshit.
I get it the fuck out of here.
I have to get the fuck Outta here where I'm going to fucking die like this.
I got to change my life.
And that's what we did.
And I kind of threw that away,
resigned from the position,
took the job as the strength coach at team quest up in the Portland,
Oregon.
Moved across the country for fucking minimum wage to clean toilets and left that
job behind.
And I fucking loved it.
I loved scrubbing disgusting,
Shitty Gym Mats at five o'clock in the morning and not sitting at a beautiful
corner office,
you know,
for x amount of dollars per year.
Because I was,
I was doing what I love and I gave myself the opportunity and the chance,
you know,
to do something with my life and get rid of the stress.
I think that's why I'm kind of veering off it.
That's what it was talking about was so stressed out and I was riding my bike.
Fuck.
I remember it was freezing cold,
fucking raining.
And I'm riding my fucking stupid bike cause we only have one vehicle.
You know,
my wife had to go fucking work.
I'm a riding my fucking bike six miles to the gym and I fucking loved it.
It was such a pure,
crisp,
cold morning and it was just so alive in life.
You know,
and it was,
everything was brand new again and I was in my mid twenties at that point,
mid later twenties at that point.
It's fucking cool shit man.
Ah,
yeah man.
Taking chances and,
and branching out on your own.
When it works out and rewards you,
it lets you know that the universe rewards risk.
It rewards calculated risk and passion.
It really does.
And if you,
if you don't live your life like that,
you're living your life.
Afraid of risk.
You God man,
you're gonna,
you're not gonna get any reward either.
You just going to be stuck.
You're going to be stuck in this bland,
boring ass grinding existence and then it's over.
Then it's over.
Yeah.
It's not like it lasts forever.
That's the number one thing.
Everybody wants to stay,
stay safe and comfortable.
Shit,
this doesn't last.
This is not going to last.
You got to be uncomfortable.
I'm uncomfortable all the fucking time.
I don't like 90 ship.
90% of what I do.
I don't like in some ways,
you know,
whether it's the exercise or writing or even performing the gist,
but I hate editing my shit.
I just had to edit my comedy special today.
I fucking hate staring at myself.
I don't like it.
It's uncomfortable.
You got to do shit that's uncomfortable.
You get over it and then you get,
but you don't like certain about it.
You've got to figure out what don't I like about it?
What's not good,
what's,
what can I make better?
And then you make it better and you keep pushing and working and the more you do
that,
the,
the more exciting it is.
The more you have.
You get a little bit of a reward,
a little bit of juice at accomplishing something and then you're onto the next
thing.
But your life is constantly fun,
filled with exciting shit.
This thing's going on all the time.
You'd got to assess and move on and move forward.
And if you don't do that,
you're just stagnant.
Your pond water that you can't drink,
you know your fuck festering.
Diane,
what drives you?
Have you ever kind of analyze like what drives you to get your ass out of bed,
make yourself uncomfortable yet again on another day that you can just fucking
put your feet up,
been laid by the pool and enjoy the sunshine.
Mental illness.
That's what drives me.
There you go.
That's what's wrong with me.
But I don't feel like I ever deserve breaks.
The only time I ever feel like I have to have a fucking brutal day where I can
enjoy television,
but if my birthday's brutal enough,
all like,
all right bitch,
she could sit down and watch a little TV and you know,
that's the only way I'll allow myself those,
those rewards.
But if I do do that,
I can really enjoy it.
I could really enjoy a nice foot up,
you know,
relaxing,
sit there,
you know,
have a,
have a cocktail,
watch some television.
I can enjoy that.
But if I don't,
I can't enjoy it.
I think a lot of people,
they're giving themselves rewards all the time,
but there's no risk.
And then there's also,
there's no,
there's no like sacrifice that led up to that reward.
And you got to enjoy the sacrifice.
You got to enjoy the grind.
You know,
when I say that,
90% of the Shit I do,
I don't enjoy.
I don't,
but I enjoy that I can do it.
You know,
like who the fuck wants to lift weights?
No.
You want the reward of the lifting weights,
you know,
and the only way you get a strong body is if you do shit you don't want to do.
When you get to that third rep,
you're like,
I'm good,
but you're not good stupid.
You've got seven more to go.
And if you don't do those seven more,
you're gonna feel like a fucking loser when you put those weights down.
Yeah.
You're like,
I'm a bitch.
I should have fucking kept calling.
And I stopped.
You know,
if you stop,
you're missing out on the whole point.
That is the grind.
That is the keeping going,
the good kind of grind,
the working towards something,
grind,
last name.
They're like,
dolce,
do you cheat or can I cheat or do you have a cheat day?
And I always retort.
Why are you going to cheat?
Have you earned it and that that's what we use.
Is it earned mills?
I don't fucking cheat meals.
Not a cheat day.
It's an earned meal.
Have you earned it?
And I'm like,
well,
I don't know.
Well then you have it like,
like you when you know if when you fucking kick your own ass,
you're totally spent.
That's when you reward yourself with your earned TV time or whatever it is.
Your cocktail.
Same thing when it comes to health and fitness and this is goes to the
accountability side.
If you want to be successful,
you want to set yourself up to succeed.
Well,
you have to be accountable.
I can't fucking do it.
I can't do it for you.
I wish I could.
There's 7 billion people on the planet.
I can't do it.
I can barely do it from my own self,
let alone every other fucking person out there and each one of us,
we are entirely alone.
100% we're by all this
stuff,
which is just a facade.
It's all bullshit.
It's easier to kind of amusing,
entertaining and often distract us.
But if we're going to be successful,
it has to be because it comes from the inside.
That driving force to make us successful so that people that want to cheat on
Saturday,
Friday,
Sunday,
they go to the gym,
they do their little thing,
they eat their chicken and rice,
you know,
Monday through Friday,
maybe they're kind of,
okay,
they cheat just a little bit here and there.
They'd go off menu,
let's say,
and then Saturday is my cheat day or Sundays,
my cheat day football's on.
And what happens Monday look fucking exactly the same.
And then they do the same basic workout for the same basic wraps and they do
that,
you know,
the same.
It's just the fucking same in there on that rat wheel.
So it'd be really,
you know,
talking to the people out there.
You really want to break out.
You really want to be spectacular.
You really want to start to fulfill your potential.
You have to make yourself uncomfortable.
You have to challenge yourself and then you have to earn it.
So with my athletes,
with myself are earned meals or maybe once or twice a month.
And what is an earned media?
I don't know.
Maybe it's my wife's birthday,
maybe you know,
it was just going to see a fucking movie or something's coming out.
And then what is my earned me on my earned meals typically a little bit more
food that I normally fucking love anyway because you know,
our recipes are fucking delicious.
I'm not going to eat some shit burger outside when I can make a kick ass grass
fed fucking burger with baked sweet potato fries,
whatever.
Eat four of those motherfuckers instead of just eating my traditional six or
eight ounce one.
So that would be a basic earned meal.
No Krispy Kreme donuts.
Oh God,
I would love to.
And they're the former DOJ.
What I would fuck,
I was the farmer,
don't former dude 282 pounds.
You know,
once upon a time I was the dude that I get a whole pizza and I put a half a
pound of provolone cheese on top.
Eat that whole motherfucker,
half gallon of ice cream,
big king size snickers bar and something colored to finish it down colored
beverages only like,
hi,
see what I see fucking crush Hawaiian punch.
And what if it was colored?
It had more calories so it's fucking drinking it.
Yeah.
Oh hell yeah.
Grape soda root beer in the summer.
And was that a cheat day or was that,
that was,
that was the time performance science.
That was me trying to hit 10,000 calories a day so I could squat,
you know,
700 800 plus pounds and dead lift,
six,
700 pounds.
That was when I was only goal oriented.
Performance oriented,
tons of fucking protein powders,
weight gainers,
creatine and CMA and fucking ATM.
Those weight gainers,
like you see those tubs.
It was not just calories and sugar garbage.
It's all fucking garbage man.
Um,
unfortunate.
They're all,
it's all preservative.
It's all chemicals.
It's all coloring.
It's all additives and it's very little of the nutrition you're actually
purchasing it for.
It's such watered down components of what is on the front label.
Just enough to leave.
So they can legally put it in there and not get fucking sued and it's a shit
load of everything else.
So your journey to becoming this MMA fitness Diet Guru,
you've kind of like changed your own life in the process.
You've sort of figured out what makes you happy,
what makes you consistently perform well and in the process you've sort of
become this guy by trial and error and education and application and now,
now here you are
in this position where,
I mean fucking 90% of the guys that I see that are doing well in MMA,
I see the guys with these dolce diet shirts on.
I mean you have so many athletes that that,
that follow your protocols and whenever someone is in trouble and they have a
hard time cutting weight,
they come to you.
How did all this start?
Like how did you become this guy?
Was it through like what you said Kurt Pellgrino and then someone,
Kurt told other people and that kind of shit.
And that was,
that was like 2002 2003 I was working with guys on team Henzel Gracie.
I was young,
started training with under Hanzo and I had been a power lifter for years before
that and I was an amateur wrestler for years before that.
So I've been cutting weight since I was 13 years old.
I was a varsity captain as a freshman,
so four year Varsity Letterman,
captain of the team and I was just,
since I was eight years old,
father,
you know,
fucking massive stroke.
I dove into body building and weightlifting at that age and I was just attuned
to it.
I was like,
honors science is biology,
mathematics and I just had that type of analytical brain and I would analyze
everything and all this shit so you know,
won't get too deep into that.
As I went through,
I was always cutting weight,
always trying to get bigger.
I was trying to get stronger.
I was rather short,
had no money,
family was broke,
want it to go to college,
how the fuck am I going to get poor kid from fucking New Jersey?
How am I going to go to college?
Only way I could do it was through a scholarship.
There's no cash.
Mom's working three jobs and there's no heat on in the fucking house so there's
no extra money for,
you know,
for this kid number three to go to fucking school.
So,
and that became my focus.
I had to focus on that and I had a shit wrestling team,
you know,
love the guys and we'd made me who I am.
But we were appropriate school.
I started on the team,
it was the second year the team was even in existence.
Our coaches were great dudes,
but they didn't have the high level experience.
None of my teammates did.
How am I going to advance the only one that's not through technique?
It's not through experience and that's through grinding,
you know,
steel on steel.
It's just being in better shape than everybody.
I had to be that guy and that's the guy that I actually became and that's what
really started more of this focus on the strength and conditioning.
Do you work with guys on strength and conditioning as well as working with them?
With Diet.
Like how do you balance that out?
Because I talked to Steve Maxwell about this and Maxwell who was uh,
you know,
really,
really well respected guy and a very,
very knowledgeable guy when it comes to a strength and conditioning and
athletics and he believes that you should do all of your strength workouts and
you're conditioning workouts like kind of building up to a camp and then when
you're in camp,
the majority of your work should be spent doing the actual sport itself.
I,
without knowing isn't entire protocol.
I agree.
You know,
on principle and what I do and how I work best is not just overseeing the
nutrition,
the Diet and the weight cut.
It's,
I call it the peaking program and I bake it out into the traditional Western
periodization program.
When I talk about 52 weeks,
it's a 12 month period as program.
When I started working with Tiago Alves in 2010,
we came up with a seven year program for him.
Now,
unfortunately he had some injuries along the way,
but it's transitioning him from the body that he once had and the bad habits
that he had once had to slowly rebuild,
regenerate,
and continue building him all the way through until he was 35 when he plans to
retire and the specific goals that we have set.
So a guy like Nick Lance,
I took over,
you know,
five or six fights ago when he was at 55 pounder.
Um,
and this,
you know,
it'll be a little long winded,
but to kind of help explain your,
your answer,
the question here,
took him over and he was doing a lot of the wrong things.
Training really hard,
totally overtrained overreaching syndrome,
constantly malnourished,
couldn't understand why his body wasn't losing weight.
He's walking around in the mid one sixties could barely make fucking 55 without
damn near Di said,
will I work with him?
I said yes,
but only at one 45 and he's like,
are you fucking crazy?
I told you I can't make 55 I said,
you'll be a world champion at one 45.
I do believe that you're undersized,
one 55 pound there and you're not training properly.
What I want to do with you is I want to add 10 and 12 pounds of muscle and grow
you into the one 45 pound class.
Blew his mind.
It didn't make any sense to him.
But to his credit he said Okay and just gave me the reins.
So from that point on I looked at you know multi month cycles,
you know,
three weeks cycles,
three months cycles,
you know,
and then the 12 years,
12 months cycle to put on lean mass.
And what we did,
we took him from 163 pounds to 175 pounds.
We dropped his body fat from probably 13 to 14 down to right about 10% and then
he's able to make one 45 consistently now easily.
So using Steve's methodology in the off season it's much more volume.
It's more strength building.
It's more muscle work.
Not exactly hypertrophy cause I don't really believe in that but we're always
staying anabolic.
That's the goal.
We always want the body constantly jet regenerating,
regenerating,
regenerating.
Cause once we start regenerating and they were breaking down and once we start
breaking down,
everything goes to shit.
So with nick,
using him as the example again,
build him up in the off season and that's where I start to break down these
three week mini cycles,
three weeks before the fight.
That's the peaking phase.
That's when everything,
the volume drops dramatically.
The intensity goes up,
but it's safe intensity.
It's not,
you're not sparring,
you're fucking hardest.
Those last three weeks you're sparring,
you're most intense and most pro fight precise without that bone on bone
collision weeks,
you know,
four,
five and six in the middle,
that's a little bit more medium volume,
maximum intensity.
That's when you're really getting your hard heart goes to build that,
um,
you know,
uh,
ability to withstand the damage that's going to happen in the fight to Callus
your body over.
And also to Callister mind,
you have to go through that the three weeks before that.
So that's,
you know,
seven,
eight,
nine,
that's more of a value in your mind.
Meaning you're just your resolve.
Like mental toughness,
mental toughness.
I mean we see guys unfortunately that they get into the octagon and they get put
a bad spot that they haven't been in before and they fault because they haven't
been there.
You have to go to those spots and fortunately,
but you have to do it in a very calculated fashion because you go there too
often.
You'll break and training and you'll give up in the fight.
You don't go there enough,
you'll break in the fight and again it's going to be the same result so you have
to touch it just enough.
And this is where that periodization comes in.
So I help oversee the overall training program.
I help the athlete.
Usually it's spar less.
I try and pull them back because a lot of these athletes are sparring two and
three times a week and I try and only have them spa once a week.
Really from six weeks out.
One good hearts bar,
proper sport and one text bar is really the methodology that I push,
save the brain,
save the body,
let's get more precise and then hit the other hard drilling into certain phases.
And then as we get farther out and it's more skill building,
we're looking to just add tools and see what tools fit the overall game,
you know,
throat 10 different techniques on the grant and see what fits.
And as we get a little closer,
we take the 10 we put it to five.
As we get to look closer,
maybe the athletes aren't going to keep one or two usable techniques that will
actually show up on fight day.
We're not trying to add new text techniques six weeks out,
three weeks out for sure at that point.
It's just fine tuning and perfecting.
But that also comes into their,
their physical preparation with their body weight.
Like what's the health again?
Health is everything.
It's mental health,
it's physical health.
That's what allows him to perform at their ultimate.
So long winded way of saying,
I agree with Steve quite a bit.
Strength,
strength building.
That's off season stuff.
We want to keep that type of strength,
that explosive strength that you know,
absolute or maximal strength that we build in the off season.
Well,
I'm going to keep that,
but now we want to turn it into a different type of strength,
like a strength,
speed or speed and Dorrence.
Um,
as we get into the specific competition and that changes depending on what the
sport is.
What happened with,
um,
with Charles Olivera,
Charles Charles over and Nicholas were supposed to fight this past weekend.
They did not fight cause Allavara showed up heavy and then the day of the fight
they pulled him.
They said he was sick apparently.
Yeah,
it was.
So I'm going to,
you're normally,
I don't really pull back the veil,
but I think because this is such a public,
um,
situation and Oliver and his team,
they've already spoken on it and unfortunately what they said was incorrect from
what we saw.
So nick and I,
this fights on Friday,
nick and I,
we get there on Monday and we're already in the system.
Nick gets to town at 164 pounds.
He's fighting at one 46.
That's the official way in weight.
And that's actually lighter than nick normally is.
But we tightened up his diet just a little bit for Charles specifically.
We knew nick was going to overpower him.
We wanted nick to be just a little bit lighter,
a little bit leaner,
a little bit faster for this fight in better condition in case it was a fuck or
three round dog fight.
Um,
Charles called nick out by the way.
So Charles asked for this fight,
you know,
after they had had a no contest years before.
So Monday nick and I,
we started doing our thing,
cutting weight.
Now my athletes don't work out.
I strongly suggest fight week.
They do not work out.
And a lot of,
you know,
coaches at all.
What do you mean?
I don't know.
We don't put on the fucking gloves.
We don't grapple.
We don't hit mits because we're now all that work's done.
We're preparing for competition,
we're pulling the weight at this point and I want to feed the athlete as much as
possible,
hydrate them as much as possible.
Keep them as strong and healthy as possible so they can endure the process of
cutting weight.
Or as I like to frame it positively as purification,
we're purifying the body as we go through this Monday,
Tuesday,
Wednesday,
Thursday step on the scale Friday face where the body's completely clean,
pure,
and we can just put the best possible nutrients back in were saying no working
out,
you mean nothing?
I mean,
nothing.
I mean the most that the most that we'll do when I talk about that in three
weeks to shred it,
what I do with Tiago.
Wow,
this is a great,
well maybe you should talk about this next.
Um,
Tiago his last fight,
you know,
he weighed in at one 71 the night before.
Wayans be using this new protocol that we're using because they're fucking
healthy.
We're not tearing them down during fight week.
We're actually,
I build my athletes to the scale.
Everybody else tears themselves down to the scale.
I build my athletes to the scale and it sounds counter intuitive and a lot of
people think I'm fucking lying or whatever,
you know,
bro,
science and out.
But no,
this is,
this is the real fucking shit.
Um,
so with nick,
what we do,
and we don't,
we don't work out.
We're going downstairs to the hot tub and we're just hanging out.
He's playing his fucking,
you know,
whatever video games,
cause he's,
he's a tech head.
He's playing his fucking games were fucking chilling out to music.
We're just shooting the shit like you would deal with your boys just hanging out
in the hot tub for a little bit.
Kamozi is coming down and hanging out with Ben Rothwell a little bit.
We're just shooting the shit down there.
Charles and his coach are in the fucking sauna on Monday in plastic.
Fucking suits and sweat pants.
All God damn.
Day Long.
Nick and I were in the hot tub for a half hour just to break a sweat,
drinking water the whole time.
Eat beforehand,
stay hydrated.
Doring go upstairs and eat again.
This is what we do and that's what we did typically twice a day during fight
week.
Every time we went downstairs to the spa,
which was beautiful at this hotel,
I'm Foxwoods.
Charles was in the fucking Sauna,
plastics on in the sauna and they would pick him up,
carry him out and just fucking let him lay in the floor.
And then they like cover them with towels.
So archaic.
And this is what a lot of athletes do.
Charles was an extreme example.
Now they're doing this on Monday.
I'm doing this on Monday,
man.
Fucking Monday.
If you're doing that,
maybe it may be.
I can see athletes doing that like the night before in the morning of,
they're doing it fucking Monday and Tuesday and Wednesday.
Now we weighed in on Thursday,
on Wednesday.
And this is fun.
So we're watching him just break this fucking kid.
He's laying there in the sauna.
I mean just not moving,
you know,
and he'd get up and you know,
he'd do and he kind of like give us a thumbs up.
He was a nice kid and nothing bad to say about Charles.
Nothing bad to say about his coach,
but what they did was wrong.
They broke him in the fucking song.
Nick and I saw it and were like,
you know,
high five.
I mean it makes our job a hell of a lot easier cause Nick's fucking great.
And you know Nick's there.
At one point,
Charles comes in,
sits in the hot tub at the very end and he's looking at nick and Nick's just
sitting there and drinking water,
you know,
shooting the shit.
And Charles over that dry mouth just sucked out big dark bags under his eyes
after being in the fucking sauna for God knows how long and just kind of laid
out on the wall.
So Wednesday comes in,
this is actually funny.
Wednesday comes the middle of the day.
Charles is coach.
They drag them out of the fucking sauna and they're just sitting there.
I took a full load,
but I was going to tweet it like what not to do.
And I was like,
oh,
that's fucking bad.
Maybe I shouldn't do that.
Maybe it should have,
I don't know.
Um,
he comes over and he's like,
hey guys,
I have a proposition for you.
And I think others fucker's not going to make weight.
They want to catch weight.
I have a proposition for you.
Like,
what's up?
He's like,
what?
You're doing right now.
This,
this is not going to work.
He's like,
you're not going to lose weight like this in the back.
I have salt and I have alcohol and I wanted poured in the tub for you so that in
30 minutes you'll lose the same amount as you'll lose in three hours doing what
you're doing right now.
I'm thinking,
are you fucking kidding me?
Salt and alcohol and the water salt.
And I'm assuming he means Epson salt and rubbing alcohol,
which is a lot of athletes use.
And I have the data on that and there's not a discernible difference and there's
actually negative effects from doing that.
You can touch on that in a,
in a second.
So I say to him,
I'm like,
now we're good.
I mean,
Nick's losing a pound every 15 minutes and we're replacing it the whole time
because again,
um,
but the data head,
and I track all my athletes.
I know Johnny Hendricks,
you know,
between 195 185 pounds,
he lose 1.2 pounds of fluid every 15 minutes.
I know Nick Lens loses a pound on the door.
I'm gonna stop you right there.
Sorry,
I'm confused as fuck you.
You make him lose weight and then you put it back on.
Now what we're doing is we're just training the body to sweat,
to sweat,
to just have the water purifying.
We're purifying,
pushing out the toxins we're giving them.
Is it distilled water?
Is Water regular purified water ever drink distilled water.
There's some sort of a theory behind that,
right?
Then you drink a lot of distilled water and it forces your body to release all
of its electrolytes or something and they leeches your body of all these healthy
minerals,
electrolytes and such.
The distilled water.
We don't do that because we're trying to preserve health.
Again,
we're not trying to,
you get them to lose 30 fucking pounds,
speed up their metabolism through proper eating,
proper meal size.
They eat small and often,
usually it's written down for everybody in the fucking world to read.
It's small and it's often,
and it's meals that we've targeted based upon their physiology from the weeks
beforehand,
meals and ingredients that suit their body.
Um,
and they just eat consistently.
We play with no carbohydrate,
carbohydrate timing.
We we play with,
the protein ratio is we keep our fat levels really high.
We keep carbohydrates in the diet all in fight week.
You know,
we keep sodium in the Diet for the most part,
most to fight week.
We elevate and then lower,
but we never dropped completely.
Um,
and a lot of people,
they just pull the carbs and they pull the salt and then they just fucking drink
the distilled water.
How do you get nick?
He's ways in the week he shows up.
He's one 64.
He's got to get down to one 45.
One 46.
Yep.
How do you get him to lose that amount of weight in a week?
We speed up as metabolism,
which matters quite a bit.
So he gets tenant one 64.
So you change his diet the week of we change.
Usually it's,
it's 10 days out.
What we do is 10 days out we increased sodium,
but not a dramatic amount of what I tell the athletes is add more saltier foods,
but not so much that it tastes bad.
Just add more than you normally do.
So let's say you're taking it the week beforehand,
so 10 days out typically should be your hardest training session.
Okay?
Cause any more than 10 days out and now we're too close,
close to the competition time.
You might not be fully recovered and you're not going to perform at your best.
So right about 10 days out,
usually the Tuesday before the fight of the following week.
That should be the hardest day.
And then everything else we start to pull way back light and medium workouts,
much shorter intensities.
It start to increase your sodium just a little bit so you can taste it,
but it's nothing that you don't like.
Never too much that it's not good and a little bit more to your water.
And we add pink Himalayan Sea salt.
Love the Onnit brand.
Actually four,
that's the one I use almost primarily to the water while they're training.
Just add a little bit more.
So we increased their sodium content just a little bit,
and then usually depending on the athlete,
Saturday or Sunday,
sometimes even Monday morning,
we pull that back.
We don't add any more additional,
we don't add additional salt.
So we rise as sodium up.
Then we pull it back down to normal levels,
probably anywhere between one to 2000 milligrams depending on the athlete,
depending on their lifestyle.
And we really focused on feeding them similar,
uh,
similar caloric content,
but more often.
So it's basically the same,
you know,
let's say 2000 calories a day,
but instead of,
you know,
five to six meals,
now we're eating,
you know,
eight to 10 smaller meals all day long.
The metabolism speeds up.
We're also focusing on more fiber,
cleaning out their digestive track.
A lot of times athletes will step on the scale with impacted food matters still
sitting inside of them.
Two,
four,
six pounds.
Who knows?
Is that a real,
that's real.
Absolutely.
Four to six
pounds of,
that's a lot of stakes apps.
If you looked at six steaks,
that lab six stakes down like six t boned,
16 ounce t bone steak.
That's a lot of fucking weight
and the fluid that they have,
that food absorbs as the notch in a person's bowels and there.
But where's it all fit?
I would estimate they say John Wayne had like 20 some odd paths.
It's bullshit.
We're not,
it's not true.
True or not,
I don't know.
But I estimate somewhere up to three pounds of impacted food matter,
depending on when your last meals where or when you're high protein are harder
to digest meal as well.
I had heard that.
That's bullshit.
The amount of like,
it's like one of those common myths,
the amount of impacted food the American average American male has in their gut
when they die.
We ever read that shit.
There's like a Snopes thing on that.
Hold on,
I'm gonna pull that up.
But please keep going.
So we speed up their metabolism,
we increase their digest,
increase their digestive efficiency,
we make sure they are completely clean.
And then what we focus on is the small sweats.
We keep the body sweating.
We allow them to be used to sweating,
but we keep rehydrating them so it's easier for them to keep sweating.
And these athletes sweat a shitload during this time.
The only time is when we stop adding water is usually the night before the day
before Wayne's or on Thursday we stopped somewhere.
Mid Day Friday we pull the water out and then we'll use what I call the step
method where it's a very simple way to not break the athlete,
to keep them sweating properly.
And the weight again comes off and it's all through hot tub,
hot bath.
It's never in the salon and my athletes.
So we don't try and fight week.
We ain't go in the fucking sauna.
We don't put on plastics unless it's like that last minute.
It's freezing outside.
We need to pull off another few ounces on the way to the venue.
Then we'll throw some plastics on.
Um,
and how much
actual dehydration is it like the though the day of when he wakes up on Friday
morning,
if it's a Saturday fight,
what does Nick Lens,
nick cut three and a half pounds on the day of way in the cit.
That's it.
He woke up the day before 12 pounds over.
We ate three meals that day.
We,
I think he drank almost a gallon of water that morning.
And just by drinking the water so frequently it pushes the water out and then we
cut.
So he woke up.
So one 46,
I think he woke up around one 50.
He woke up at one 58 the day before he floated,
you know,
two pounds off by the time we got to the tub later on that night he went to bed
at one 50,
so we lost about six pounds and that's usually half.
And that's a good estimate.
The day before we want to lose about half the night before you're going to float
one to three pounds.
Typically,
you know,
while you sleep.
And then the next morning is usually two to four pounds.
So it's very small controlled,
you know,
elimination of wait and it's water weight and he's still eating.
He's never not eating.
He's still picking.
He's not having these big meals.
But we go from meals to,
you know,
kind of snack size to now it's handfuls just to keep as metabolism moving,
keep his body processing the food,
keep pulling the nutrients,
keep his blood sugar stable,
keep his brain on,
keep his mood elevated so it doesn't feel like shit.
Hmm.
Uh,
according to a Snopes,
John Wayne did not have that much packed,
impacted in his body,
but Elvis apparently had a lot,
but it's because he was taking drugs.
He was impacted hack.
They couldn't get it from the painkillers.
Right.
But I've heard that too.
That's why I want him to look that up.
Yeah.
It's a,
apparently,
it's like almost,
you would be in such incredible pain if you had that much food impacted in your
bowels,
which makes sense.
So if you were to eat,
you know,
how many pounds of food do you think the average person do it eats in a given
day?
200 pound guy,
you know,
six pounds,
eight pounds,
maybe 10 pounds of food.
You wake up at one 90,
you go to bed at one 98 or so.
There's fluid in there,
but you've pissed and shit out some.
Do you,
um,
account at all for biological variability like this,
Nick Lance have a different Diet than say Tiago Alvin?
Yes.
Does he,
how do you know,
like what to do for each individual?
So we stick with prince.
The principles never change.
And that's really the scientific base.
The principles never change,
but the individual application almost always does.
And it changes with the same athlete from fight to fight because the athlete has
never the same no matter what we're doing in this camp three months,
six months from now.
It's a different athlete.
It's a different physiology.
It's a different training pattern.
It's a different mood,
it's a different lifestyle.
And how,
so give me an example.
Like Tiago Alva.
So with Tiago,
what we did in the beginning,
you know,
he missed weight with John Fitch in 2010 I started working with him two days
later,
brought him down,
fought Jon finch and your John Howard.
And his weight issue was gone.
So,
and then he had some injuries.
He had his knees fixed,
he had his shoulders and arm fixed.
He was on the shelf for two years,
uh,
25 months actually.
We came back and he fought in Orlando in April and the new and improved Tiago
had been on the meal plan almost the entire time,
was eating properly those 52 weeks out of the year.
And he does his Sunday Fun Day and he has a little barbecue,
but that's controlled and that's okay.
We allow that to with the gray.
But he would really follow the meal plan from about 12 weeks when the fight was
offered.
He went on and he didn't break.
He didn't go off.
So when I got to him three weeks before the fight,
and Tiago is one of the few athletes I actually traveled for for an extended
period of time anymore.
And I went and stayed with him and he was one 96 or one 98 three weeks before
the fight jacked probably,
you know,
8% 9% body fat slow and he's fucking looked awesome.
Slowly but surely I tighten up his diet.
You know,
I tightened the wheels and the switches just a little bit.
Really made sure he was getting enough food to fuel but not enough to spill
over.
And we were able to slowly bring his weight down to the lower.
Nowadays if he's 8% body fat lowering his body weight.
Yup.
What do you,
are you causing atrophy?
Like what are you doing?
To a degree we're trying to,
with him we're trying to eliminate a little bit of muscle or reduce some of the
muscle volume that he has and that's it's all water weight cause you can tell
that he definitely looks slimmer.
And when he fought Seth Bazinsky,
he looked great,
he looked awesome,
fought great.
He had a great gas tank at me and he looked really good in that fight.
But that was,
I found it fascinating that he weighed so little a day before the fight.
Yup.
When he entered into the cage,
what did he weigh?
One 94.
So how are you doing that?
So pulling him down the same exact principle,
different foods for Tiago than what lance eight Tiago is much more of a,
um,
uh,
protein and fat metabolizer.
Nick Lens is much more of a,
of vegetable and produce metabolizer.
Um,
they perform better.
All their analytics are much better when they have those types of foods and that
just comes through experience working with these guys.
So Tiago was more heavy.
It was,
you know,
chicken and steak and eggs,
Avocados,
you know,
different types of oils and seeds to really bring him down anytime he has,
the heavier carbs outside of the breakfast bowl,
oats in such,
Barry's first thing in the morning,
he tends to blow it up and really hold on in that water.
So we slowly eliminate that and he said no pastas for him or things along those
lines.
I think we did pasta probably two weeks out where we do what's a refeed,
you know,
every,
uh,
once a week we'll do a refit where we go really high carbohydrate,
but we'll stage that with a lower carb carbohydrates either before or right
after.
Um,
so we'll do the refit definitely once a week,
sometimes twice a week depending on how close we are.
And what's the benefits of a refeed?
It's to refill the body of loss glycogen to make sure that usable energy is
available.
Um,
and it's also a mood elevator cause a lot of times the athlete starts to get a
little,
you know,
shitty if they're not getting more carbohydrates in the brain runs on
carbohydrates also.
So you can see the mood kind of deep decreased just a little bit.
And also performance,
like working with Manny can Burean right now to drop him from 45 to one 35.
Got Him on the first program,
the initial program and it was just a little bit too low carbohydrate and he's
like,
ah,
his mood was down just a little bit.
He didn't feel that snap and practice.
And we really just brought him up about a hundred extra carbohydrates per day
and he fucking felt amazing.
So it was really trying to find the line that is exactly what they need without
spilling over.
And once we got that,
we got them feeling good for 10 days,
we're able to stage it down just a little bit and he even better.
So now we're slowly in in that last three week phase,
the peaking phase.
And he's,
you know,
now he's like 148 pounds yesterday,
which his last fight for him to get under one 55 he felt like he was going to
die.
So now he's training at one 48 feels fucking amazing.
Fully fed six plus meals a day,
but everything's kind of perfectly controlled.
Wow.
So this product
called that you do,
you make,
you make a specific one for each fighter and you sort of work with them,
same principles.
What happened with Bj Penn because Bj Penn subset with you after his fight and
you know,
set a lot of shit in the press and just really wasn't happy with it.
Yeah.
He said his exact quote was without the ivy,
you're nothing like he,
he wanted to not use intravenous fluid retention.
He didn't want to get an ivy to rehydrate.
Yeah,
he,
the Ivy was available and ready and the doctor was on call and he didn't want
the IB and I didn't even want an ivy.
He didn't say,
well,
no,
that's not true.
Days before he had said he'd never used one before.
He was worried about how he would feel.
He said he would play it by ear if he did feel like he needed one,
but he didn't cut any weight and that's why I didn't disagree with him.
Now he runs the show.
He's the boss of the camp period at the end of story and that was very clear.
He didn't want the ivy and I didn't disagree with him because he didn't cut it.
Announce he was eating and drinking on Wayne Day,
walking over to lance.
This is not an athlete that was dehydrated.
It was not an athlete that was suffering.
It was an athlete that looked amazing,
was bouncing around talking to everybody full of energy.
Did he need an IV?
You know,
I'm not a doctor,
but he didn't want the doctor to come to administer it and I have to rely on the
the athlete,
you know,
it's his body.
It's his choice.
He said he'd never used one before.
He didn't want one.
He felt great as what he had said.
Perfect.
Well here's shit a shit.
Load a house full of food and fluid and everything that you need to consume,
so enjoy it.
Now that same fight card I worked with Ronda Rousey.
Ronda Rousey didn't use an Ivi there and she cut over 10 pounds.
She never ivs.
She had never used one before,
a little nervous to use it.
Chose not to use it,
didn't use it and went out there and look like Rhonda always looks because she's
just never had it before.
Now,
if she had used one,
maybe she would've looked even better or maybe it would have thrown her off her
fight last 10 seconds.
I know when she fought me,
she take her fight lasted into the third round and me,
she's a very well conditioned athlete.
One of the better conditions,
female athletes in the game.
And Rhonda looked amazing and that was a scrap,
not,
not at one point that Rhonda looked like she was at a loss and she had no ivs,
no ivy in that fight.
And how much did she cut?
Now she cuts about 10 pounds.
She gets in,
she's fights at 35 usually she'll get down into the lower forties just that day
before me.
She's getting the fight week,
usually between 48 and 50 and she does most of her training and the loaf.
How did Bj,
Hey,
get
down to 145 pounds.
Bj is a guy
who fought at one 70 because he didn't like making one 55 yeah.
So all of a sudden we see Bj training getting ready and he looked so thin.
And what did he do?
He was back when we film the ultimate fighter,
he was 162 pounds.
He was in a low one sixties back then when and then they,
they broke off communication with me.
You know,
after the ultimate fighter was over,
I didn't hear from anybody from their team,
their camp until the very end of May,
which is just a few weeks before fight week and they were in a bit of crisis
mode.
Now I didn't get to Hawaii to first actually,
you know,
be a part of the camp and the team until June the ninth,
which is less than a month before the fight.
And when I got there,
Bj had said he weighs,
so wait,
what do you weight champ?
157 pounds.
But I went out last night with Dominick Cruz and we had some pizza and I weighed
one 57 today.
And I'm thinking,
fuck,
why do you need me to be here?
You know,
the fucking,
you know,
dolce diet dude,
if you're 157 pounds,
I mean you're 10 pounds over what the weight class is after eating some bad
shit,
you're probably closer to 55 54 I'm assuming.
So it was kind of,
it was an anomaly.
It was really an odd situation.
Um,
how did he lose the weight?
You know,
just eating a little more peace,
paid more attention to his food as he got closer to the fight.
Those last couple of weeks I was there,
I didn't prepare any meals for them.
I stayed in a completely different location.
He stayed in one area.
I stayed a few miles away in another area.
It was a weird situation,
was one of the oddest training camps I had ever been a part of.
And I was there for less than two weeks.
Physically in Hawaiian,
had very little influence unfortunately.
And I made some very strong suggestions and I made,
you know,
very strong observations to members of the team of what I saw and what I am
accustomed to and what I think would really benefit.
What did you have issue with?
Um,
it was the training,
you know,
frequency and just the training frequency.
Yeah.
I don't believe it was enough.
It wasn't training enough that for all the other athletes that I work with
trained much more often.
And it was Bj training once a day,
but not quite every day.
And the type of training was less.
There was no,
and then we'll,
we'll just compare it to Frankie Edgar's team and I'll,
Frankie Edgar has Mark Henry there who's a worldclass striking coach.
He has Steve Rivera there who's one of the top wrestling coaches in the country
and then he has a Carlisle NATO.
There is one of the top Brazilian Jiu Jitsu coaches,
practitioners in the world.
And then frank has got a shit load of UFC level guys that he's training with on
a daily basis.
And BJ had none of that.
He had a coach who was a nice man who from my understanding has no experience in
boxing or coaching.
You know,
professional athletes certainly don't have a worldclass UFC MMA level.
There was no wrestling coach there and you know,
the only,
the top level Jujitsu guys,
of course Bj who's very accoladed but his brothers were there and it didn't seem
like they had any influence as far as technical proficiency or strategy or you
know,
game plan or training.
And it was,
you know,
minimal.
The only training camps there of,
you know,
training partners,
their value where the two guys I brought in at the last minute,
which was Nick Lands in Merseyside backtick now lens left very,
you know,
he got there and he left because he didn't want to be there.
He didn't feel like it was going to be a good training environment for him.
So he left early and then Massaad stayed.
But Marsan,
you know,
a young,
tough kid and Marcel was actually a great training partner for Bj and really
tried to do his best to mimic what Frankie was going to do.
So it was a tough situation.
Is it one of those situations where
in all fairness,
Bj,
who's a great champion,
who's a real MMA legend is almost too strong of a personality to be coached
because he's been so successful and because he's been such a destroyer that
points in his career that he has something in his head and who the fuck are you
to tell Bj Penn what to do?
That could be,
that could be.
It was very,
I,
you know,
I don't know why there was no coaches there that we're able to truly make
influenced the suggestions that I made were,
and I made them officially and they were accepted but not responded or reacted
to.
And it was just a matter of,
you know,
this is,
that's the direction he's choosing to go and he's either going to win and look
like a fucking genius or he's going to not win.
And he's gonna make the odd makers look like a Jean.
In all fairness.
There's other issues besides diet.
There was also his upright boxing style that confused the shit out of a lot of
people.
No one,
no one understood.
He had this narrow stance and he stood completely straight up.
It was very odd.
And,
uh,
when he was asked about it,
he said that it was very effective for them and training and that,
uh,
it had been,
they came up with it to somehow or another reserve energy.
So by not lowering his body weight,
body,
meaning by not lowering his stance and pushing off of his legs more by standing
up straight,
he would extend less energy.
It would be less difficult for him to do.
I found that incredibly bizarre.
And the last thing you should ever be thinking about if you're about to fight
Frankie fucking Edgar is conserving energy.
I mean,
God damn you,
you better be ready to go balls to the wall for five fucking rounds because
Frankie is going to
Frankie's going to,
yeah,
when we were on the ultimate fighter setting,
October,
Frankie was training twice a day himself and then he was training twice with the
athletes on the,
the show.
Frankie was seen in every gym in Las Vegas training with their best and top guys
and he was surrounded by his coaches the entire time.
I mean,
that's who frank is and that's who I knew Bj was going to be competing against.
Bj was at his best when he was at the,
sorry to interrupt you,
but was with the Marinovich has agreed,
agreed.
And Erna bitches and uh,
Jason Parillo was working on his striking who was visiting Bisbing striking
coach and they were able to really put together great performances sherk
and Diego and Joe Stevenson.
And that was,
that was prime be amazing.
I don't know why that there was the dramatic shift in change and in training
protocols and saw and style.
It says he wants what he wanted to do I guess.
And that speeds.
He's the boss.
It's so hard when you're a fan of a guy like that where you,
you almost want to just be able to like get inside of his head and just,
you know,
man,
if you had like a Matt Hume type coach,
someone that you could completely listened to,
someone that you trusted and respected enough to run your entire camp,
this is the guy is going to tell you what your strength and conditioning
protocol is.
This is the guy who's going to tell you what,
what kind of sparring you're going to do.
This is the kind of,
uh,
just drilling you're going to do.
You're going to do all this stuff that this guy says,
a guy like Bj Penn would almost be unstoppable.
Absolutely.
It's hard band.
It's,
it's,
it's really a fascinating sport in that this sport has evolved before our eyes.
And we've seen the training like change and move and adjust.
And it's one of the reasons why I brought up the idea of whether or not people
have unreal expectations because of it performance enhancing drugs.
Cause it's,
it's,
it's very confusing and a lot of ways people there,
everyone's sort of imitating the successful behavior they see around them.
You know,
this guy uses ropes,
he swings ropes around.
I got to get some ropes.
You know,
this guy likes to fucking use a tire and a sledgehammer.
Fuck,
I need a tire.
You know,
it's everywhere.
Yeah.
I mean that's what we see.
We see everyone sort of imitating what successful and what people have done
successfully before them.
And then this guys like fate or they're confused the shit out of her body cause
he's throwing rocks at fucking throwing punches with little hand weights.
And that's basically all you ever see from them.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's weird.
It's a weird sport and that it's not like pro football where you know,
you go back to the Jim Brown error and need change to today.
You know,
you've seen 50 years of evolution and it's all sort of culminated in the last
couple of decades and you see science and nutrition and strength and
conditioning protocols of all sort of adjusted.
But with MMA it's not just running,
it's not just moving left and moving right at the same time you're learning the
thousand plus possibilities of any Jujitsu match your learning,
the 500 plus possibilities of any combinations and kickboxing,
you know,
you're learning so many skills.
The combination of wrestling and judo,
the combination of Jujitsu,
sambo catch wrestling and the combination of,
I mean there's just so many variables.
There's so much shit to learn on top of all the strength and conditioning.
So it's not as simple as this guy needs to learn how to squat 500 pounds and
fucking push that sled.
Yeah,
no,
this is a lot of other shit you have to do too.
And if you do too much of one and not enough of the other,
you won't be at your best.
It's this combination,
the strength
and conditioning and of being,
you know,
a guy who understands all the variables of mixed martial arts as well.
Absolutely.
It's,
it's almost like no one really knows how to do it yet.
It's still young.
I mean we're still evolving.
You know,
as a sport though,
people have been fighting for years never like this and never at this level,
never with so much on the line,
you know,
multimillions of dollars available now for the top dog.
So there's a,
as a race and that's obviously what brings in the PE,
but it's also what's pushes athletes like Rhonda Rousey forward to constantly
evolve and work on her striking more and find new ways to dye it and do strength
and conditioning better and use her mental visualization approaches to really
make sure she can be at the,
you know,
the top of that cresting wave.
So she's not getting stuck behind that.
She's really at the forefront.
And when athletes like that,
it's a,
it's a crazy time when it comes to these things.
It really is a crazy time.
And the thing about the performing in sands,
the performance enhancing drugs,
I mean they exist in all sports of course,
but in MMA it's almost like there's not enough time in the day to do everything.
There's so many different things that you have to be on top of that an athlete
almost doesn't have the time or the physical resources,
like their body can't do all the work that's required and that's where
puritization comes in.
That way you're able to segment what we're going to be working on for this three
week phase and then we're going to work on something different but synergistic
on the next three week phase and we're slowly going to be the best possible
version of ourself at that time.
When we step into the octagon or step into the competition circle and then it
all starts over again and we look to add more tools.
One of the other things that Bj's camp said was that you kind of restricted the
amount of food that he ate.
The day of the fight is not true and there's a line,
a lot of the things unfortunately that said we're factually incorrect and I
chose not to comment.
This is the first time I'm even commenting about it and I went on,
I'd go to the on the underground everyday and a lot of the people in the
underground seemed to have a pretty good take on what the reality of the
situation was and I didn't feel the need to personally comment.
And what I'm going to say is that there he had a house full of food.
I personally brought over tons of amazing food that was available.
He was two minutes from a whole foods next that was right down the street from
him.
You know,
there's his house had,
you know,
shit,
10 gallons of water in it and a gallon of coconut water and a full running
faucet and there's sea salt everywhere.
And you know,
just,
you know,
a big,
I brought up the huge vat of the power pasta with grass fed beef and all the
organic,
what is that?
Power Pasta?
It's,
it's a brown rice pasta.
So it's,
it's a higher carbohydrate content food.
And it was,
I made two 16 ounce boxes of it,
which would basically feed like a family of four really fucking big dudes or you
know,
the family of six or so,
two pounds of grass fed ground beef was mixed up in there and just,
and they'd like to peppers,
two red peppers and two green and two red onions and you know,
just really high quality nutrients and you know,
a
full fucking smoothie,
massive,
you know,
handful of Kale,
handful of spinach,
handful of Redgrave's,
handful of blueberries,
handful of strawberries.
So you didn't,
you don't restrict their calories at all.
The day of the fight.
I don't restrict anything.
And again,
I had very little influence,
very little influence and that's,
that's clear.
I br I was more like a,
I was a chef.
I would bring some really delicious food and you know,
some things would get eaten and some things wouldn't.
It was nothing.
I was saying don't eat this or don't do that.
And everything was available.
And who was saying that you had restricted as food?
Because that was one of the big things that was going around and know a lot of
it's just internet hearsay and somebody hears things and they create a thread.
People in his camp wasn't it?
It wasn't anybody in his camp.
It was people that seemed like people from his area or information was fed to
them by somebody.
And I'm not really going to speculate because it's not worth my time to comment
and I don't want to turn it into anything bigger.
I understand,
but it just,
it was factually completely false and incorrect.
And I spoke with very,
you know,
high ranking members of his team and we've had,
this,
the factual conversations,
we're all in alignment as to exactly what happens,
which is a really nice thing,
but it's kind of the,
the public conversation that just continues on and that's just not correct.
So do you think that what happens is after fighter loses they,
I mean,
it's an interesting thing that happened with Travis Browne.
Um,
Travis bound to this intro interview and I really love Travis.
I think he's an awesome guy.
I think he's a great fighter,
but he's also super honest,
which I thought was really cool.
And he said that after he lost to Fabricio for doom,
he said,
he goes,
I went through the whole process.
I blamed myself.
I blamed everybody around me.
I blamed,
you know,
I took turns blaming people.
He goes,
I fucking cried.
I did the whole deal.
And then I figured out,
all right,
what do I need to work on?
What do I need to change?
What do I need to just,
he's working with Edmond.
Uh,
Ron does a trainer on his striking and trying to tone things up and change some
things and learn some new skills and learn some new variables that he could add
to his fight game.
But what I love about the fact that he was,
he was honest about how after the fight there's this instinct to sort of blame,
blame himself,
blame others,
rotate,
you know,
no,
fuck it.
It was everybody else's fault.
It wasn't me.
And,
um,
after the BJ fight,
I kept hearing all this shit about,
you know,
blaming Mike Dolce and like,
man,
how much fucking impact can a guy who's telling you what to eat have on how you
fight?
Because what I saw in that cage was a guy getting overwhelmed by a guy with a
fucking incredible gas tank with a better strategy by the number two guy in the
world who has two wins over him previously.
So,
you know,
there's just bad matchups.
Right?
And that maybe that was one of it.
Frank has been more active.
He's was the number two guy in the world at the time.
Bj was coming off of massive layoff.
And we knew it was a very uphill battle.
I was as shocked.
I mean I was really hurt when I heard the first and I saw
the things being said and kind of the finger being pointed my way cause I know
what happened and I know what my influence or lack of influence was and I will
say I will go down with the fucking ship.
Any athlete that knows me that I work with knows the type of person I am and I
think I've built it,
built a solid reputation within the industry and it was,
it was just uncalled for.
It was unfair and I kept my mouth shut because I try and be,
I want it to be a professional and I didn't want to say anything because bt has
got a lot of fans.
I'm a fucking huge fan of the kit.
I still am a huge fan of the kid and I understand because I have fought before,
I've lost before and I've been hurt before and I've wanted to blame and I still
couldn't blame.
But what does that going to get?
And with my,
you know,
defend myself here for a second.
I know what I did and I think I was probably one of the only bright positives
with true world class experience that was around him.
I didn't have to be a part of that campus cause he's isolated.
He's on Hilo on very difficult.
Ireland is very,
very difficult when you're the most famous fucking person and you've got people
showing up at your house,
knocking on your door to get an autograph.
Things.
It was,
it was,
it was difficult.
It was very hard situation.
It was his people knocking on his door.
Yeah.
Trying to get an autograph.
I mean I feel bad for the guy that's,
you know,
luckily there's not that many people.
After a couple hours you're done,
you're done.
But it was the old town anywhere he goes,
people are honking the Horn Santa,
he's a superstar specific.
I mean it here,
he's a superstar there.
He's just,
you know,
he's like the king over there.
Right.
And it was,
it was hard for a lot of different reasons,
but you know,
for,
to see the things said and basically the way that they were men,
you know,
we look,
you look at the fight,
you look at what happened that had nothing to do with food and had nothing to do
with body weight.
There's,
you know,
we posted a video of him two days before Wayne's,
he woke up at one 48 fully fed,
fully hydrated,
saying it's the best.
He fucking fell and his entire life.
And then,
you know,
I understand what you're saying.
Um,
I found it incredibly fascinating that you said the athletes don't work out at
all the week of,
and one of the reasons why is because I happened to be at,
um,
Uriah Faber's,
uh,
Jim this past weekend when TJ fought and when Danny Castillo fought.
And when I got there,
Danny Castillo was working out.
Yeah.
The day of the fight he was hitting mitts with Dwayne.
And,
uh,
you know,
they put in like a good fucking 20 minute workout.
I mean,
he was hitting Mitts,
man.
I mean,
he wasn't just,
he wasn't going like 10% speed,
like just moving his body around.
He was working out.
Yeah.
Footwork drills,
you know,
combination.
He looked great.
Yeah.
You know,
and I was kind of shocked and I asked why and he said,
well,
when he rehydrated he felt a little bloated,
but he always does that.
He always gets in a workout.
This was the Wayne's winning pretty rehydrated no,
this,
yeah,
after weigh ins rehydrated than the day of the fight.
He worked out the day of the fight.
And I do agree with something along those lines.
They have to fight to get the fluids,
every athletes
a little bit different.
We do with that with Nick Lance and he's the one who gave me the fucking black
eye on Friday before Charles canceled the fight.
We put them through usually,
you know,
abbreviated three rounds just to get a moving and make him feel good again.
Just we,
I approach and a lot of the athletes I work with,
we approach fight day like another fucking day.
Okay.
So hard sparring day.
So,
oh,
I see what you're saying.
So you treat it like as if he's just going to do some hard sparring that day.
So when you have him work out to get the fluids moving as it were,
what,
what's the idea behind that?
Is that like the,
the rehydration process,
the ivy and everything like that?
You want everything moving through the body and make sure everything's working
properly so there's no surprises.
But we're not overworking the athlete.
We're warming them up and then we're just calling them right back down again,
making them big.
Part of it is also,
it's building confidence because they go through the weight cut process and
sometimes you feel a little shitty and you're like,
fuck,
do I still have it?
I felt like shit.
You know,
Shit.
Yesterday I felt like yesterday I got,
he looked so big yesterday and get in there and they feel,
you know,
obviously nick is,
weighs in at 46 and he was probably four to six closer to,
you know,
65 the very next morning and felt like a fucking machine.
And he left that room with a smile on his face.
Like I'm gonna fucking kill this dude.
What do you do when it comes to guys like heavyweights?
I W most heavyweights,
in my opinion,
I'm not saying that they should cut weight,
but they should all be fighting somewhere between 10 and 12% body fat.
The chubby heavy weights with the fat belly.
That's a lazy athlete.
Fatal fate or could have been better.
I believe he could have been,
God forbid he could have been better.
What about cane?
Cane looks a little fat.
I know,
but he's a monster.
Could be.
Look at Daniel Cormier.
Yeah.
These guys,
just because you compete in an unlimited weight class or nearly unlimited weight
class,
it doesn't mean you can have an unlimited bodyweight.
What's the proper body weight for performance?
For most athletes,
it's somewhere between eight to 12%.
Is there a proper body weight for a heavyweight?
As far as like when you get too heavy,
you're dealing with gravity,
you're dealing with mass that needs to have blood pump through it because isn't
the one variable that's not very different in people the size of your actual
heart that the heart tends to be similar in size.
Slight variables more similar in size.
So like a guy like big foot Silva.
Yup.
Or Brock Lesnar's is a better example because bigfoot actually has gigantism is
a real issue.
But Brock Lesnar an enormous giant and then a guy like say Kris Carr Yasso who's
fighting for the flyweight title.
Their heart has probably way more similar in size in any other part of their
body.
I would agree with that.
Maybe the cock,
I dunno about that.
I just throw that out there for some real,
Chris has bigger problem.
Maybe he's got a giant kids got balls tell you that,
but I'm pumped.
Um,
tough guy,
Chris Carr.
Jasa interesting fight coming up.
But my point being,
is there a number where a heavyweight like shouldn't like some be a lot of
people think the most effective way to somewhere around two 44 heavyweight.
And I agree.
I think they think that because that's what Cain is what Kevin Kane eating
properly and he's the fucking dominant champion of the world.
So I'm not saying he should do anything,
but there's no reason why any professional athlete should be walking around with
excess,
nonfunctional weight.
And a lot of what's floating around canes midsection or athletes like Canaan.
He's one of the better conditioned.
But without that eight 10 1216 additional pounds,
how much faster would he be?
Force production would probably be very similar unless he really sits down on a
single punch or one single blast.
But he probably be faster.
He probably be more agile,
he'd be more capable of scrambling.
He'd be able to do a few more things with no loss in strength.
So you think if he got down about two 30 and load as body fat to about 10% he'd
be even better than the best heavy weight ever?
I believe so.
I mean,
I don't know if Cain is the best heavy weight ever,
but in my opinion it's between him and fade or there's two best heavyweights of
all time in my mind.
Yeah,
and their cane and fade or yeah,
look at Tyson at 20 pounds of fat to Tyson.
What happens to Mike Tyson?
He no longer becomes one of the most dominant heavyweights in the world.
Is that true though?
I mean,
I don't know about that man.
Like the Tyson that knocked out Larry Holmes,
you put on 10 pounds on him.
He's still gonna Fuck Larry Holmes up put 20 but is he still able to cover that
distance?
Is he still going to have that,
that fast twitch Movement for eight and 12 rounds.
First three rounds.
Everybody looks like a fucking monster,
you know in,
in boxing where first five minutes in MMA,
first round,
everybody can move really quick,
but then as time goes on that wait start gravity starts to pull on you but okay.
In,
in response to that,
the two guys that we were talking about,
both Cade,
both Kane and fader or both guys that had high body fat who are known for their
high output and they're long fights with incredible endurance and they could
have been better.
It's not really true though,
I believe.
So is it,
is it possible that carrying around a certain amount of fat aids,
your endurance,
is that possible?
Absolutely.
But what would that line be?
Just and me visually,
I'm not in their camps.
I don't know.
So we're just kinda throwing shit at the wall right now.
I say,
and all the athletes just experienced,
we're gonna throw some bro Science out there right now.
Eight to 12% body fat for the heavyweights,
closer to the 12% not down to 8%.
You know,
for the lighter guys,
8% or cell makes more sense when [inaudible] was at his prime.
Yeah.
What do you think his body fat was?
Um,
he held a lot of fat in his belly,
but there's some fights where you could see veins running through his shoulders
and arms.
You know,
he had rather skinny legs,
so he was kind of ass heavy and you know,
stomach oh bleak.
Heavy.
And that's where he was handling a lot of our carrying a lot of the,
wait,
what was it?
Probably you know,
14 the 16.
Did you ever talk to him?
You,
you're find out what his diet was or anything with love to I've slide a fucking
Russia to find out what's going on with that guy.
I think he was at his prick.
Well certainly there's skill involved.
I mean he had tremendous them a price on both skills.
Yeah,
I know what you're going to.
I mean without a doubt.
He had
incredible mental toughness and his ability to perform under pressure was
fantastic.
There was a lot going on there.
But I would also like to know what his actual training protocol was when you got
to see those,
uh,
those highlights when he did strike force of him working out and stuff.
But you don't know what the fuck that is.
You know,
a lot of times guys would just,
you know,
they'll tell you I hit the bag for our promo and you know,
he'd have him fucking throw casting punches at the bag.
You don't really know what,
what is he actually doing?
What's his actual training and most of that stuff on TV,
it's mostly fake.
Most of the athletes,
they don't run with the fucking parachutes.
They don't do a lot of that,
that type of training called sexy training and it looks awesome on TV,
but that's not really what they're doing on the daily and the higher level
athletes really trained very basics.
They focus on the basics.
Then you know,
they get really good at the fucking basics and they start adding some higher
level technique.
Same thing on the strength and conditioning side.
Matt Brown does a lot of really wild shit,
man.
He does a lot of really wild strength conditioning shit.
Do you work?
Do you work with him at all?
The Mortal Brown?
Yeah.
No I don't.
Unfortunate we've played with it and we were cast members on the ultimate
fighter years ago.
We're still buddies,
but I haven't worked with him specifically.
I'd love to down the road that I think that'd be a fun part of my career.
Yeah.
He's a guy who,
I've seen some of his workouts,
they're fucking brutal.
He doesn't like a really unorthodox stuff.
A lot of crazy lifts,
dead lifts and all kinds of obviously a very thin guy,
but obviously very physically strong.
We've trained together,
you know,
even after the show Matt strong as hell.
He's a lot stronger than he looks.
He looks like that thin lean guy.
He's got,
he's fucking strong when he gets his hands on you and he's like granted.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I mean as we're talking about this and talking about different styles and
different people's training,
um,
it's,
it is interesting that there's no one answer.
Like,
this is what you have to do in order to,
you know,
do x.
You have to start out with,
you know,
why and put it in,
w and there's no answer,
right.
It's like everybody has to figure out what works well for them.
And when you see guys like re readjust and rebound and try to reassess their
career,
like,
like Overeem is a perfect example.
Overeem is now at Jackson's and he,
you know,
he just fought against Ben Rothwell and got knocked out in the first round look
great for a little bit until he got clipped.
Yeah.
But,
um,
you know,
he was doing things a lot differently.
Throwing those,
a oblique kicks to the knee,
which a lot of people don't like.
They're upset about that.
I don't like those either.
Yeah.
It's a weird technique because you're not supposed to attack the knee itself,
right?
Isn't that,
what's the story?
What the rule is?
I think it's like within an inch or two of the need,
depending on,
I forget the exact role now,
but,
but nobody calls you on it.
I have,
haven't seen him throwing a bleak kick and an inch over the knee.
No one's going to say,
Hey,
don't attack the knee.
Nope.
Especially when you're lying on your back and you throw one up kicks.
People throw them right at the knees and no one says a word.
Yeah.
You know,
like,
uh,
when Kunaki and Hicks and Gracie fought.
Yup.
You know,
remember that Hixon fucking blasting them right in the knees and fell off of his
back.
It's interesting
man.
You look at like Eddie style of Jujitsu [inaudible] verse the Gracie style or
just the word Lat Bang Moitai verse.
You know,
Duke Roufus,
you know,
it's like different philosophies,
different approaches,
but they all fucking work really well.
And if you speak with Dwayne,
he's going to say,
no,
this is the system.
Right?
And you're gonna smell that he's got it.
And then you'll watch Pettis fight and you know,
Duke Roufus has got his own,
he's got his own and that shit fucking works.
It works real good.
Strength and conditioning I think is very similar and it's,
the athlete is really going to gravitate towards what suits them,
but it's all,
you know,
like I said,
the athlete changes,
which is why my,
we have the principles,
so the principles don't change y'all Duane,
let's say throw a punch with your right hand.
Left hand has to be blocking.
I think Duke would say the same thing,
but the individual application,
that's where it changes on the individual basis per athlete per time.
They compete or fon different athletes.
So the principles are always the same.
But we always have to evolve the application.
I'm sure.
Just like Eddie's doing every night he goes in the gym,
he's like,
Oh shit,
I saw this fucking white out do something that just totally killed the black
belts move.
What?
Let me fucking try that.
If there's variables introduced through that don't exist in striking.
But there's also striking variables that don't exist in Jujitsu.
Like the idea of throwing things at like a 50 or 60% outright output instead of
100% with each technique.
Yeah.
Whereas some guys like Jeremy Stevens,
perfect example,
Jeremy Stevens is a fucking murderer.
He throws,
everything is designed to knock your face into the dirt.
I mean everything he throws is 100% on it and he's just works hard to be able to
do that.
But its volume is much lower than say a guy like Nick Diaz who Nick Diaz will
come at you and he'll throw like many punches at like 50 60% and put it on you
and then throw some hundreds in there,
you know,
dig to the body with a hundred go upstairs with a hundred and then more 50 50 50
50 and he just puts volume on you.
So you don't see that.
And Jujitsu,
you very rarely see guys like hit moves at less than 100% you know,
when you're,
when you're trying to get a teen,
someone,
you don't try to get a team them at 50% you know?
Sure.
You locked that bitch up,
you're squeezing with everything you got.
Yup.
So it's a,
it's a fascinating thing,
the,
the different approaches for different body styles because some guys also,
they don't have like Dominick Cruz,
great fighter,
great athlete,
great champion,
does not have that sort of one punched Jeremy Stevens power.
He just doesn't possess it.
He doesn't have the body for it.
You know,
just this is what the universe has given them.
They've given him a,
you know,
he's a high volume,
high output,
high discipline,
excellent condition that's important imperative for him to be able to put on the
kind of performances that he puts on.
Yup.
Whereas some guys just go out there and try to Paul Daley yet,
you know,
excellent technique,
but everything's designed to murder you.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
It's an interesting growth and evolution of the sport and it's really cool to
see the different athletes,
different body types,
and see this new generation now coming out there.
Because what we're seeing guys like Cruz and Dillashaw,
he's the champ now,
but he's part of a younger generation,
but there's another tier below him now that's going to be coming soon in and
make Dillashaw look a little,
you know,
not one dimensional,
but a little slower,
let's say,
you know,
two,
three years from now,
there's some fucking kid in the middle of nowhere that's going to come out and I
can't imagine that.
But I know you're right.
It's gonna Happen,
right?
GSP came out and we're all like,
God damn,
this dude is like an Olympic gymnast.
And look at what he's doing.
And then you know,
you have a guy like Dillashaw coming out,
moving the way he does,
putting his wrestling together,
all the faints that he's dealing,
hitting with power.
You know,
kind of like what you were saying about Das,
where they're able to off speed their punches in the air strikes and really
change angles.
That's awesome.
South and he's seen the level of the wrestlers and athletes are just coming in.
They're just off the chain to like guys like Hendrix.
You know guys like core me a,
just like when Carme fought Henderson,
you're like,
what the fuck?
Who the hell is ever done that to Dan Henderson?
Yeah,
call me and he's got him flying through the air.
He's hitting him with trips as he's moving back.
He's doing like a lot of crazy shit that you very rarely see.
That's when I think I realized how high level core me really is.
Oh yeah.
No one's like you said,
no one's ever done that to Dan.
Dan's lost a couple of fights,
but no one's ever been able to do that to Dan fucking Anderson before.
That's also interestingly enough,
Dan,
off testosterone replacement terms,
one of the first guys that we've seen compete on and now off,
and he had competed off before against Rashad Evans.
Yeah.
Lost a decision against Rashad Evans,
a very close fight.
Right.
Um,
and that was a,
because they were fighting in Winnipeg and Winnipeg,
so athletic commission didn't.
That's right.
But I,
I,
you know,
I believe Dan,
when he says that he takes a very little,
you know,
I believed them.
I believed the anthill.
Yeah.
I mean who is on it?
But a lot of these guys also,
one of the reasons why they test low is because they're overtraining.
Absolutely.
And that's something that people need to take into consideration when they
discuss training protocols is that what's happening with a lot of fighters is
they're going through the same sort of thing that they went through in wrestling
practice and what wrestling practices,
fantastic four is developing mental toughness.
I believe there are no tougher athletes in the world than someone goes through
high level wrestling camps.
Someone who goes to Purdue,
like a John Fitch.
You know when you,
you go through these fucking camps,
you go through Iowa,
you know,
you go through these,
these high level wrestling camps,
amateur wrestling,
college wrestling camps,
those people are fucking and a mall.
They have a level of mental toughness that if you don't understand it,
they're going to wake up 15 minutes earlier than anybody else because they know
that no one else is awake.
They're going to run an extra mile because they know no one else is gonna run
it.
They're going to,
they're going to do all these different things because they pride themselves in
being uncomfortable and grinding it out,
and there's good in that,
but there's also bad in it and the bad in it is the,
the physiological reality of the body's ability to recuperate and that if you
tested any of these high level professional wrestlers or a amateur wrestlers
rather at at their highest level when they're going camps,
I guarantee you a lot of them are going to have low testosterone.
Absolutely.
I would agree.
I think it's just because their body's being broken down and it's just the
sheer,
dogged determination of their own mind that allows them to get up every morning
and keep doing it.
Yeah.
Look at Hendrix.
He,
when he fought Robbie fractured shin,
torn biceps,
he had a fractured Shin to fractured chin.
And during the fighter from the fight,
from training in training,
he was fractured chin torn buys,
partially torn by us that would tour all the way during the fight.
And uh,
didn't even blink,
didn't complain one time.
The only way I found out was just kind of like in passing,
he was just joking about it.
You know,
any other athlete.
Most of the other athletes,
they're canceling that fight.
They're pushing it back three months,
six months,
you know,
and then that's,
and then Johnny goes out there and is able to get a win because of that mental
toughness.
And that's one of the things that makes Johnny so fucking great is that
physically,
I mean,
he's a really strong dude,
but he's not tall.
He's not long.
If he's got fast hands,
you know,
he is fast,
but his feet aren't very fast.
He doesn't cut angles or move his head movement to,
well it's his,
his main,
it's his brain.
It's his mentality.
He's got that championship mindset that's just been ground into him through a
whole lifetime of wrestling.
Well he taught also his dad's a fucking psycho.
Fucking awesome.
You know,
it's funny.
Is it low?
He had two options or three options.
Wrestling,
wrestling or wrestling.
That's all good.
Wrestle or you could wrestle or you could wrestle and uh,
you know,
like how he made him do pushups and sit ups and Chin ups and shit.
When he was a little boy,
he was doing fucking 500 pushups.
I mean he just had that kid as a youngster with a very high tolerance to work
and just this,
this drive,
he pushed him so that everything else will be easy.
I mean,
he made it so everything at home,
all the training he did,
all the wrestling practices were so fucking hard that everything else would be
easy.
Yeah.
And look at him.
UFC fucking middle welterweight champion and should have been the first time he
fought GSP.
Agreed.
In my opinion.
I mean the,
he got the title with the Robbie Lawler fight,
but I thought,
I thought it'd beat GSP and the only people that disagree that I've talked to or
people that were like in that Henzel Gracie camp that were a little bit biased
and thought that George one like round one,
which I didn't understand.
I think damage is more important than anything.
And I think Johnny without a doubt did more damage in that fight.
Like they pointed to the Guillotine attempt in the first round,
but I didn't think that was a successful attempt.
I thought that was,
you know,
I thought it was never close.
It's like,
did you see um,
uh,
Scoggins versus John Moraga this last fight?
Yeah,
the first gay team was very close to second gear teen locked it up.
George never had a gay teen like that.
You know what I'm saying?
It wasn't like one of those where it was like Scoggins barely got out of that
first gate team or Morocco locked it up.
Yup.
But he was in deep shit and then he caught him with a second one.
That's not what the kind gay teen that Hendrix was caught in in that first
round.
So I didn't understand anybody saying that they thought that GSP one
a little bias I think you know.
Sure.
But I'm biased words,
Hendricks and I'll admit that.
But watching and trying to be impartial,
I think Hendrick's clearly one and I believe George and some of his team,
I think they know cause the two athletes when they walk out,
you know,
if you kind of won or lost and I think that one and it felt their mood,
their energy and just the way that they,
you know,
we interacted afterwards,
very professional,
respectful.
But I think they knew that Johnny had won that fight.
Truly.
How do you tell
a fighter to stop?
Is there,
is there a time where a fighter should be told to stop?
Cause if George was my friend,
I would tell Georgia stop.
Yeah.
And the reason why I would tell Georgia stop is because we did some sort of a
fight metric thing where we calculated all the times he's been hit inside the
octagon and he had been hitting the head 880 [inaudible] times over the course
of his UFC career.
And I'm like,
what is,
what's the number where a guy can walk?
Cause he talked to George,
now he's lucid,
you know,
he speaks well,
but I know that he was having migraines.
I know that he was having memory issues.
Yeah.
And um,
and I think there's only a certain amount of times a guy can fight.
There's only a certain amount of blows that guy can take.
And George,
if he stopped now,
could he have another fight?
Yeah,
yeah,
he definitely could.
Could he come back and be great but very possible.
But could he come back and take some damage that five years from now we're going
to see a much compromised George?
And that's possible as well,
right?
Probably not.
I've had this conversation with athletes before and it's,
it's difficult and it's emotional and it's,
you know,
it's in their best interest and sometimes you know,
they've gotten mad but they know it's out of love and care and concern and it's,
there's a risk to reward.
And you know,
anytime an athlete,
whether you're an amateur,
you're making millions of dollars,
there's a risk.
And what is the reward?
Is it some sort of personal challenge?
You try to,
you know,
scare away a demon or are you trying to provide a college education for your
daughter?
These are things that they get put on the scale and then become intellectual
conversations to have.
And you then you say,
all right,
is this worth the risk?
But a guy like GSP,
I mean,
he's proven everything.
He's a legend.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
He really has proven everything he can prove.
I mean,
he can come back and beat other fighters,
but is he ever going to elevate the status of his legend?
He's one of the greatest of all time,
if not the greatest welterweight of all.
It's him and Matt Hughes.
Yeah,
those are the two greatest welterweight of all time.
Yeah.
And you know Matt is from a slightly different era.
There are areas overlap,
but you know,
in my opinion,
Matt,
it was a game changer,
you know,
so I think he still goes down as possibly,
it's in the debate for who's the greatest.
Sure.
But George,
he's not going to ever elevate where he's at.
Where he's at is a fucking all time legend.
Yeah.
You don't use more of an off time.
Legend.
I have one more fight.
It'll be another all time.
Legend.
No,
he said an all time legends there go.
I mean and as far as I know,
he's very wealthy.
I know he had to give a lot of money up to his fucking farm.
Right.
Manager though.
And this is a lot of gross that's involved in that man.
Yeah.
I had spoken about managers recently and it kind of got spun the wrong way.
I don't know if you heard anything.
I'm no talking to Ariel.
I said quote.
So I hope nobody out there is going to quote this out of context was athletes
need to get rid of their need to fire their managers and hire attorneys.
And it wasn't meant to be that every athlete needs to get rid of the manager.
Cause I said there's some great managers out there but there's some managers out
there that they have their hand too deep inside the athletes pocket where the
athlete can't excel and can't develop themselves as a professional because
they're spending 20 and 30% of their purse and all their earnings going straight
to their manager.
And then the athlete has to pay for an attorney to come in and do contract
review.
Then they have to pay for an agent to come in and bring in sponsorship.
Then they have to pay a striking Jujitsu wrestling strength coach.
Then they have to pay their income taxes.
Then they have to,
you know,
put food on the table for their family.
And you know,
at the UFC level where these contracts are much more strict.
And that's really what I was talking about.
It was during the Kelvin Jaslin I'm comments.
Was it the UFC level?
There's not a lot of negotiation room for most there's,
it's more of contract review.
Legalees and you know,
some of the managers came out and they said,
yeah,
you know,
they were pissed at me and I asked them all,
all of them specifically.
I said,
how many of your clients have come to you because their manager fucking sucked.
And they're like,
oh shit,
a bunch.
That's what I'm talking about.
But maybe you're awesome.
But at the same time,
these athletes,
they need attorneys to really look at the paperwork and yeah,
there's a building phase and you getting them in from air,
you're getting them notoriety and such to get to the UFC level.
But because you get them there doesn't mean that you should stay there.
And a guy like Mike Pyle,
he fired his manager a few fights back.
He talks directly with Joe.
Sylvie does all the negotiation.
He gets to keep all of his money.
He makes more money now.
And he hires an attorney to come in and do the contract review and such on a per
hour basis or a per contract basis.
And he speaks very openly about this.
He's one of the guys who was in the UFC and he's one of the higher paid athletes
out there doing it.
Well,
you know,
obviously I love the UFC obviously.
Um,
it's a huge,
it's a huge honor for me to,
to call the fights and to be a part of the organization.
But I think the only way that the UFC is ever going to satisfy the athletes,
I mean the only way the athletes are ever going to be in a situation where
they're completely,
totally happy with what they get paid is if they're at the top of the heap.
Yeah.
I mean,
when people compare it to Floyd Mayweather,
Floyd Mayweather,
I made extra money.
Do you have any fucking people or Floyd Mayweather won it's Floyd Mayweather
period.
And everybody else who fights him,
they take a drastically reduced purse and they're super lucky that they get
that.
Like whatever my Donna got for that first fight,
1 million bucks or something like that.
Biggest pay days.
Correct.
Yeah.
And by the way,
that's not what GSP get provides GSP a lot more money money than that.
And GSP as big as he was is never the draw that Floyd Mayweather is.
Floyd Mayweather is a draw like internationally,
nationally.
He's gigantic.
I mean the,
the amount of [inaudible] he's also the promoter.
I mean he's got a lot of shit going on in less a fighter becomes a part of a
promotion.
I mean it's just not the same thing.
You know,
if the,
if the UFC like when Oscar de la Hoya was golden boy productions and you know,
when he was fighting as well and make an insane amounts of money in that.
Sure.
There's,
again,
it's only one Oscar de la Hoya and there's also the UFC like it or not.
And I love it.
They're essentially the number one game in town and it's not like there's a
close number two.
Whereas Bob Arum golden boy,
you know,
there's,
there's all these different promotions.
The money team,
there's a lot of different promotions when it comes to promoting fights.
Whereas the UFC is like,
there's Bella tour,
you know Bella Tours.
Not bad there on Spike TV.
They're doing real good.
You know,
I'm a big fan of Scott Coker.
I'm a big fan of spike TV,
but the reality is there's a God damn huge.
Who the fuck is the UFC heavyweight champion?
Cain Velasquez?
Who's The Bellator heavyweight champion?
I don't even know who he is.
I don't know who it is.
I know.
Was it used to be Coal Conrad?
Was He?
Nope.
Maybe not even.
Wasn't his,
but he retired retired money.
Ben Asker and used to be the welterweight champion and that who's the
welterweight champion now?
Is it Lima is a Douglas.
Amen.
God,
I couldn't tell you man.
He's world class kicks,
right?
Was he the one?
Maybe he did.
I mean,
I know he wins a lot.
He's world class without a de Lima could compete with,
in my opinion,
everyone else in the world.
But Ben asked her and kind of ragdolled him,
you know,
and Ben ask her now is fighting for one FC.
So it's like the difference.
Okay,
there's Schlemenko,
he's the middleweight champion shore.
But someone from his fucking camp talk to him in a fight.
And Tito Ortiz hope he got paid for that was like,
Eh,
I mean it's like a grown man fighting a guy who is in high school.
That's what it looked like.
I mean,
Tito was fucking enormous and that Blanco's probably truly a wealth or wealth at
the UFC,
right?
Yeah.
In my opinion.
And somehow or another he's fighting Tito.
When Tito got on top of them,
like this dude is not getting off the bottom.
Tito is very underrated submission skills as well.
He's good.
Yeah.
He can't knock them.
Huge disparity.
Yeah.
Just giant.
And then,
I mean that's your middle weight champion.
You just saw your middle weight champion,
get choked to sleep.
Not good for any by a guy who could fight it.
Heavyweight.
Yeah.
Like what the fuck are you guys doing?
And they did that just to sell a paper view.
And the whole thing was just preposterous.
And I think that,
uh,
you know,
unless that changes,
there's the,
the,
the amount of money fighters get,
like there's,
it's not going to be the,
the level that you're going to get inboxing until boxing and the UFC.
I mean,
until there's a,
I mean maybe it'll be one of the new champions,
it'd be Ronda Rousey
that gets your first or her first $50 million cause she kinda has that
transcendent appeal.
Sure.
I mean she really is sort of transcending this sport.
She's the biggest star right now in an MMA.
Sure.
And it's because of what she does outside of the octagon as much as she does
what she does inside.
And that's something I try and talk to athletes about the athletes that I
haven't had the ability to influence.
And that's what I see other athletes do.
A guy like Alan Belcher,
Alan Belcher makes far more money running his gyms and online training business
than he does when competing as a professional athlete inside the UFC.
And he makes a good payday inside the UFC and the athletes,
they need to understand that they're as big or as good as they want to be and
they can certainly build their brand in areas like yourself.
You find areas that you enjoy and that you're good at and we're,
you're not good at yet but you want to be good at.
So you bust your ass to push your way into that field.
In that niche.
And athletes,
they have more than enough time to do that.
Whether it's flipping real estate like Bristol Morandi's doin right now and he's
making his Bristol Bristol Monday was a float and UFC a couple times fault for
strike force.
He was on the ultimate fighter a couple of seasons back.
Um,
he's flipping real estate in Las Vegas and the article came out about him
recently.
He makes shitload more money doing that.
Then he does fighting and he's fighting because he enjoys fighting.
You know Alan Belcher,
what he's doing,
what Ron does,
dealing may,
Ron does outside the octagon.
Money is going to eclipse what she makes inside the octagon.
She's such an anomaly though.
I mean,
how many hot chicks can beat the fuck out of dude.
I know,
but she's going with what she has.
And there's a lot of athletes out there that can go with what they have.
They all have some look at what Ludwig did.
He went from being a high level fighter at the end of his career.
He transitioned to a coach and he'll be a much more successful financially.
And you know,
business wise as a coach grown is affiliate system building his brand that way.
And he made good money as a fighter,
as a top tier fight or knocked out Jens Pulver one the k one Max North
Americans.
I mean he did some really good things inside the sport.
So just taking that,
that concept.
So if,
and I'm not,
you know,
showing for the UFC here,
but I'm saying if athletes are sitting home and they're looking at their
paycheck at the end of the year saying they're not happy with it,
well there's a lot of other ways that they can monetize that they can use their
brand,
they can use what they do to get out there and build.
And it's not sitting back waiting for sponsors to just hand them a check to put
on a t shirt or to hold up,
you know,
a,
an energy drink.
There's other ways to go out there and,
and take care of it.
Yeah.
It's,
it's tricky for fighters to find that and sort of explore that while they're
also trying to improve their skillset and improve their conditioning and also to
have the energy to do it.
Now people are fucking exhausted after they're done training.
You know,
at the end of the day they're just like,
oh Christ.
It's hard to think of.
I mean,
I don't know,
Fuck Rhonda does it,
but that chick never runs out of energy.
I mean she's just a dynamo.
Yeah.
And that's also one of the reasons why she's so damn successful,
not just outside of the EOC but as a fighter,
you know,
cause cause she has that fucking law,
whatever it is.
And I don't know why I did that.
Wow.
Did she's gotten that wrong.
40 smart.
It's like whatever it is,
it's a monster.
It's a monster inside of her that comes out.
Like,
legitimately,
she just happens to be hot,
you know?
But it's all those other things that make her who she is,
And it's hard for people to find that.
She also has that sort of personality that that polemic,
you know,
sort of like she's,
she's a controversial figure.
Absolutely.
She's,
you know,
naturally,
she's naturally a fuck you bitch.
Like that's her.
Like all that shit you do with Misha Tate on the show and people like she's
fucking crazy.
Yeah.
I guess what,
everyone's great.
It's crazy.
They're all crazy.
That's when Jon Jones and Cormier,
when they had their,
uh,
their mix hot and they didn't know it and they record that.
He's like,
Hey,
pussy pussies still there.
Like that's the,
that's you,
you guess what?
That's what you get.
That's the kind of,
you want to,
you want a guy who's a fucking destroy,
like John Jones,
you're going to get that guy.
That's what you get.
That's,
those are the type of guys that win world titles.
Those are the type of guys they'd become the youngest ever UFC champion.
There you go.
Those Jon Jones type characters.
I mean,
they're not there.
They're naturally controversial.
Absolutely.
They're not like the rest of us,
fortunately or not.
And that's what makes him special.
I agree.
But I don't know what John is not more more um,
loved or popular then than he is.
I don't understand it because in my opinion,
I will never miss a fucking John John's paper view.
And I would think that anybody who,
like I've heard people say,
oh,
he's cocky.
Oh he's this.
And I wonder what the fuck is going on with that.
And I'm,
and I'm going to throw this out there.
I'm just going to say it.
I wonder how much of it is racism allow.
I really do.
I did.
Damn.
Oh,
did you know why?
Because I think they look at him as this cocky black guy and I think a lot of
people have an issue with that.
And I think that if he was a white guy and he was doing the same thing,
I'll like Chael Sonnen.
I think you'd be way more popular.
Chain was never the,
the successful athlete did.
John is,
but I think that Chad was way more successful as a promoter than John Is.
And John has not been nearly as cocky or outwardly a braggadocious as chail was.
But somehow or another,
when chail did it,
first of all,
channels,
very entertaining,
very articulate,
best shit talker bar.
None in my opinion,
combat sports has ever seen.
Absolutely.
I said,
I've said he's better than Muhammad Ali and people were like,
you're crazy.
I'm like,
I'm not crazy.
I'm telling you the truth.
I think he is a better shit talker.
Me As a fighter.
No,
no,
not the best fighter,
but as a shit talker,
I think he's one of the most articulate,
funniest shit talkers ever.
Yeah.
I mean,
I really do believe that
you think people Chell resonated with the public because we all knew or felt in
the back of our mind that he wasn't truly serious maybe,
and we were appreciating his art,
his skill of doing it where with John,
we think,
yeah,
maybe he's serious about this,
isn't it?
Maybe.
And I'm a of John like you,
I'd love to watch that kid fight guy fight,
you know?
Yeah,
he's a super and I think he,
he goes through a couple more wins and beat some tough guys.
If he beats core me a,
he will become the Ali of our sport.
He has that type of young,
brash,
outspoken outlook.
And I want to see the next chapter two there,
the second act of John Jones and then the third act.
I'm really excited as just a fan of the sport to follow his career,
follow his arc and you know,
um,
friends,
you know,
with core may of course also.
So I'm not going to pick a horse in that one,
but it'd be really interesting to see how John Goes.
It is without a doubt.
I just find it,
I always found it odd when everybody would get upset at him and say that they
didn't like that he's cocky or that he says like he's 25 and he's the UFC light
heavyweight champion.
He's the youngest ever UFC champion.
He destroyed show gun to win the title and I mean destroyed.
He threw a flying knee and hit shogun and the Chin five seconds into their
fight.
I mean,
Jon Jones is a mother Fucker,
period.
He's a motherfucker.
But for whatever reason people have had an issue with that.
And I know I'm going to get a bunch of hate tweets.
Woke you in your fucking bullshit.
Fucking we got white guilt
racism.
That's okay.
I'm still reeling from the fucking pro wrestling fans mad at me for the last
episode.
I'm not really folks.
It doesn't bother me.
Uh,
pro wrestling fans were really mad at me cause I was my friend Tony Hinchcliffe
was on,
I was mocking him and joking around about pro wrestling.
I really don't,
uh,
just for the record,
I don't hate pro wrestling at all.
And I loved it when I was in high school.
When I was in high school,
I was a fucking huge pro wrestling fan.
Me and my friend Steven Arduino,
we would get together and fucking,
he,
we were on the wrestling team together.
We'd always joke around about being super fly off the ropes.
You know,
I was a huge wrestling fan,
but I was 14,
you know,
do I watch it today?
No,
but I understand.
Appreciate it.
I was busting my friend Tony's balls cause it made for a fun podcast,
but it fell fucking wave of misspelled.
Hate towards that have come my way.
Holy Shit folks relax.
There's other things to be upset about.
Okay.
I don't,
I'm not really up.
I'm not really mad at yeah.
Settled down.
But um,
I'm probably going to get an equal amount from the area and race then there you
go.
Mad At me for defending Jon Jones,
the Cookie Negro.
You know,
look,
I think that,
I really think there's something to that.
I think people want a guy who was so physically gifted and young and brash and
black and rich.
They want him to have more humility or fake humility as it were.
And I think John's trying that a little bit.
That's one of the reasons why core me.
I was like,
you are so fake.
Like you're so fake.
The core.
Mia was saying that to him because he's,
I think he's trying to counteract how people feel about him.
It's gotta be hard to be that young and successful and still emotionally
developing.
I don't want to say mature,
but he's still learning to be a man right.
In his own skin and to have that type of success.
So he does.
He deserves to be fucking cocky for what?
He's a cop.
No doubt what's going.
It's,
it's inevitable that he's cocky.
If it's,
it's almost impossible not to be at that age and at that level of
accomplishment.
I think everyone is evolving.
Yeah.
I mean,
you evolve till you die.
You change and grow and learn.
If you're not,
you're,
you know,
you're stagnant and you're rotting away because I think I'm a better,
whatever I'm better at now,
I'm better than I was a year ago.
And if I wasn't,
I'd be disappointed.
And I'm 47 I mean,
when I'm 48 I guarantee you I'll be looking back saying whatever I do,
whether it's podcasting or comedy,
I'll be better at 48 that I am at 47 and when I'm not that,
it means I'm fucking dying.
It means the gear stop turning,
the nootropic stop working,
the testosterone replacement.
Failing fucking,
there's gonna come a wall.
You're going to hit that wall.
I haven't hit it yet.
When I hit it,
I,
I'll know I hit it.
But I think that when a guy like Jon Jones is 30 and looks back at who he was
and he was 25 yeah,
he'll have said some things that he didn't think he should have said.
But the,
the trials and tribulations of being that guy are almost unimaginable to just
distress.
And this,
the,
the pressures and all that jazz,
absolutely no shit
with now the scrutiny that's on a guy like that,
with all the social media available,
all the,
you know,
cameras in his face.
Just the attention at it as 25 year old,
all of us,
everybody listening at 25 we're all fucking idiots.
And if you're 25 right now,
you're gonna look back 10 years and be like,
Jesus,
I was an idiot.
You know?
So it's fun to watch.
You know what John's going through and I would love to see him just go straight.
He'll fuck you all,
you know,
double fingers up in the air.
I'm the best in the fucking world.
Fuck you.
And not try and play.
Not pandered to the comments anymore and not try and be the Christian dude,
not trying,
you know,
make people happy.
I think that's real though,
I think is a part of him.
Look,
he has the fucking biblical tattoo on his chest.
I don't think he put that there for a show.
Yeah.
I think there's part of him that really feels like that,
but there's also the part of them that's this,
this remorseless warrior.
Sure.
You know,
there's both,
there's both of those things.
It's a,
it's a constant conflict going on.
I mean,
I think he definitely tries to be a good person.
I think he definitely tries to be a good father.
I think there's definitely,
sure.
But he also is the guy who choked the older machines to sleep.
You know,
he's,
he's also the guy that,
that submitted.
Vitor Belfort.
He,
he's also,
he's,
he's just a real destroyed.
He,
uh,
he,
so when channel was fighting him,
I was,
I was helping child for that one.
And John like wouldn't look at shale and like there's a photo and I made a
comment on the phone,
like,
you know,
Dolan's must be scared.
He's not even looking at jail is just,
you know,
some,
hype in the fight.
And John saw me backstage and he's like,
man,
he's like,
what the fuck?
He's like,
why are you saying I'm not scared of him?
Like it was,
you know,
in my face a little bit on that goddamn champ,
like
the fibro.
Right.
And then,
you know,
I see him like,
a week or two later and he was just such a sweet guy and he's like,
man,
I'm sorry about that.
He was like,
oh,
I hyped up at the fight.
I know you're just kidding.
And he's like,
I
was just in that zone.
So the dichotomy of character,
you know,
in my face,
like,
Yo,
fuck you.
And then remorseful afterwards,
not for African man.
If you were really bad about that,
dolce you're a good dude.
Like Blah Blah,
blah,
blah.
So yeah,
and I think that's real.
I don't think he was just doing like some sort of PR.
No,
it was,
we were alone.
There was nobody around.
Nobody watching both times.
Yeah.
And it's not,
I don't think it's damage control.
I think,
you know,
it's a fuck the unimaginable pressure of being that guy.
Yeah.
You know,
and no one is rumbled Johnson's out there that are rising up,
putting people to sleep,
you know,
rumble Johnson with man.
Whew.
He's the scariest in my opinion.
He can do things to you that other guys can't do.
Absolutely.
That fucking fight with him.
And Phil Davis opened a lot of people's eyes.
That was terrifying to watch Phil Davis just in this full defensive mode that
we've never seen him in before.
Fill it and get him down one city.
No,
no.
He didn't even come close.
That's a scary man right there.
Yeah.
And Rumble connects on anybody.
It's 99 yeah.
What he did to fucking little nog man.
Whew.
I mean people beating Little Nog,
but they haven't beaten the fuck out of him like that.
No.
He beat the fuck out a little nog and put them to sleep.
Yeah,
I mean,
that was terrifying.
Yeah.
He's a terrifying guy.
Absolutely.
It'd be fun to see.
He started out,
he is a perfect weight cutting example.
He started out fighting as a fucking welter weight,
weighing 230 pounds,
dropping down to one 70 insanity.
And we spoke multiple times about the possibility of working,
and I told them,
no,
I don't think it's good and I think you should move up.
And I,
oh,
he's a good guy.
For anybody that doesn't know that,
he just know that persona of Anthony Johnson.
He's a really a good smart guy.
And he felt committed to one 70 for whatever reason at that time.
But you know,
going to one 85 two oh five and he's had success in heavyweight also,
right?
Yeah.
Success to have you at two oh five I think that's where he's,
he's just a killer.
I obviously couldn't make 85 against bell fort back in the day to a five it's
just a nasty weight class for that dude.
And he's not a young,
he's not an old guy either 30 yeah,
he's 30 and he's also emotionally very mature now.
He's a different guy and he's not,
you know,
he would get overwhelmed and fights like the cost check fight or some of the
high pressure fights that he had before.
Sure.
But I think also having the failure,
the losing his position in the UFC,
leaving going somewhere else and then deciding to fight all the way up at
heavyweight.
Yeah.
Andrea Alaskan fucked him up as a heavyweight.
He's a monster man.
Yeah.
He's a fucking monster rumble Johnson.
And it's,
again,
he's gone through the journey and he's become a better man because of that
journey and talks openly about it.
I mean,
after he fought little Nog and I interviewed him and he thanked the UFC for
cutting him.
It's awesome.
It's like just one of the best things that ever happened to him that made him
wake up and realize what he was doing wrong.
And he was saying,
yeah,
and,
and I said about the weight cutting things like,
yeah,
don't cut so much weight.
Feel good about it.
He's a fucking big guy,
man.
Fucking big dude.
He's a big guy too.
I would see him in between fights.
It was unimaginable that I can make one seven.
He said he would go in the sauna for an hour just to lose a pound like back when
he was making 70.
Oh my God.
Just killing,
killing,
killing his body to get it done.
His body failed.
Um,
one of the fights [inaudible] or one of the fights where you didn't make weight.
Body failed.
Like his legs stop working.
Yeah.
Like he couldn't walk,
you know?
I mean,
he was on death's door.
Literally.
Yeah.
Literally fucking how about Barao look,
we,
when we were almost out of time here,
but that's a perfect example of a guy was fucking up cutting weight the day of
the weigh ins.
They change opponents.
He gets pulled out of a fucking title fight because he can't make weight and he
falls asleep.
He blacks out getting out of the tub and bumped his head.
It's a comedy of errors right there.
Not to point fingers.
I think the whole team has to accept responsibility for that.
Taking the fight way too soon,
pushing for the fight,
taking the fight.
The kid had,
you know,
was concussed in the fight against the first fight against Dillashaw and he's
fighting three months later.
They should have been out for six months before they even scheduled.
Even thought about scheduling a flight.
We all know that.
I agree 100% and then to have to cut all the way back down again.
There's no way we can expect it as body respond.
I'm not sure how they cut weight,
but I know those guys,
they don't cut weight in the healthiest manner.
They really struggle and sacrifice to get down.
We see them all the time,
so they just tortured this poor fucking kid and then you don't let an athlete
just from experience.
You don't let an athlete stand up.
Athletes,
if you're in the bathtub,
you roll out of the bath tub onto the floor and you slowly stand up.
You use hand grips.
You have two people in there to help you stand.
Never should a coach's hand be off you and whatever cream allegedly they put on
them.
That stuff.
Abilene and stuff doesn't work.
I have the analytics to show it.
I'm not bashing any companies,
but Abilene is not designed for weight cutting.
No,
it's not.
It's a moisturizer.
Moisturizer and it's a lot of these old wives tales.
That's the Epson salt and alcohol rubbing alcohol like I was talking to story
before about all I'll,
so you put alcohol in the Tub and what that does,
those fumes,
they create respiratory distress.
They tons of headaches.
Chris Kamozi was kid.
He's like,
what the fuck man?
They came in,
they put alcohol and the Tub.
It's like now I've got,
now I've got a headache because of what all there is team did downstairs in the
spot at the fucking hotel.
It was,
they poured it into the spa at the hotel where everybody else got in there.
Yeah.
W world is is come on your boat.
EPSOM salts is good for you.
It's a natural source of magnesium.
It's good to take Epsom salt baths.
One of the best ways for your body to absorb magnesium.
It's one of the added benefits of sensory deprivation tanks because the,
this,
the sale he needed water is absent salts.
You actually,
your body actually absorbs magnesium.
It's a great way to get it excellent skin.
It's not going to make you lose additional weight and that's something that we
can argue back and forth and people listening or I do that all the time,
try to do the same tub with the same temperature in the same physical state with
and without the Epson Salts and watch what you lose.
It's going to be almost identical.
And you have all this document.
I do,
I do.
Well that's a difference as you,
a lot of these that are,
you know,
these weight cutting guys and these people that people get brought in is the
amount of documentation that you have and the amount of just raw data just from
dealing with various athletes.
It's all,
everything we do with database,
it's database experience.
Days it based,
it's research based.
I mean it's,
it's proven and then it's this never perfected but it's always evolving.
What worked last time against,
you know,
with everybody.
Well,
that's what we're sticking with and if something was an anomaly,
what we consider it and we look at t look into what we research it,
but we don't add it to new protocol.
Is there any failure that you've had?
Like is there any one fighter that you worked with you like man,
I wish I could go do that one again.
Um,
now I've never had an athlete Miss Weight other than myself.
Freshman Year of high school and the state wrestling too.
I don't think that counts.
I'm not going to just say it to freshman year.
No athlete under my watch has ever missed weight.
But the one I would like to Redo,
I mean the Hendricks one in Dallas,
I would have loved to have make weight on the first time with that one.
But there was a whole comedy of errors and Phil also,
you've got to stop to think about the fact that he's pretty seriously injured
yet torn Bicep,
cracked Shin,
pretty fucking crazy in the first place.
Absolutely medical checks in the middle of the day.
We had to stop cutting and then start cutting again.
We left the scale.
This is our fault for leaving the scale and a closed and open the closed or open
gym,
sorry with a bunch of knuckleheads jumping on his scale.
So there was quite a few things and looking back that we could have done better.
I would have loved to have rewound that one.
Um,
you know,
I should have got in,
had another commissioner come over and check the scale again when the first
commissioner called them at one 71 and a hair one 71 and a half,
which he wasn't sending one and a half.
He was 70 and a half and he had his underwear on.
There was quite a few guys who had issues with that scale.
In all fairness,
there was a backstage scale that weighed very different than the onstage scale,
which can happen occasionally and it's a real issue.
Like people were calling for calibration for recalibration and they're like,
we can't recalibrate.
That does happen.
Certain commissions and time to time.
It's really,
it's tricky.
It's tricky.
So it's all,
it varies with commission.
A lot of folks don't realize that like when you see it,
like a few fighters miss weight oftentimes because the backstage scale is
different.
Like they thought they were wrong,
they were fine,
and they get on the onstage scale and it's a different weight.
Absolutely.
We've seen,
I've been at events and I won't say the promotion where the scale got dropped
and then you step all,
you get on the scale at the early day,
pre ends,
a scale got dropped somehow,
you know,
between the venue and the,
the hotel and now all of a sudden it's got a crazy reading.
Like you're saying right now.
Um,
they're last minute.
The scale gets switched because it gets,
you know,
it goes to the wrong place or it doesn't get through.
So I've seen almost every Addis you I've been at,
you know,
I don't even know how many Wayne's now and it's not as easy to weigh in properly
when you're trying to keep the athlete as healthy as possible.
You're not just trying to get the athlete to 170 pounds and just leave him there
for four hours.
You're trying to minimize that period as much as possible and really just skim
the top of the wait and let them bounce right back up.
Cause we're trying to preserve their health,
which is going to increase their ability to perform to the best of their
ability.
So you know like with Hendrix and the weight,
it was a matter of getting them out of here,
get them calm again because he's freezing cold.
It was so cold in that place.
It's freezing cold,
shaken.
I'm on the scale.
The chaos begins title fight on the line.
Let's get 'em out of here.
Let's calm them down and then let's get the weight off of him.
Let's keep him healthy.
Let's keep them confidence,
keep them happy and get them back on.
So that's what I would like to Redo.
And when you kind of guy like Hendrickson has a torn bicep and a correction,
how close were they to not taking that fight?
There was,
it wasn't even a consideration.
What was it going to?
Even if the arm was completely useless,
there's going to just fight with his left.
He was going to go and fight with one hand.
Yeah.
Fuck,
that's fucking Johnny Hendricks says,
well I love the kid.
There's no quit in him no matter what.
There's just no quick,
no.
Seems like ridiculous.
Like if you have a torn ACL and you can't move,
I find anyway,
if I was,
if it were up to me,
I wouldn't let my athlete fight in that one and that's either good or bad.
We can debate that.
Also,
I'm not going to put an injured athlete out there to get his bicep torn off and
possibly ruin or possibly lose his only opportunity to fight for a world title.
Let's say Robbie went up there,
one that last round or Johnny had the default because he tore the bicep and
couldn't lift his arm.
Ref saw that judge saw that medical,
you know,
doctor saw that called the fight on this,
on the stool.
Crazy things happen and then he loses his bit and now it goes to the back of the
line.
He's got to fight three,
four fights against it.
Stack division.
Maybe he never gets there again.
So that would be one consideration.
But a guy like Johnny man two time,
Ncaa Division One national champion,
he goes out there and he knows how to get it,
get it done,
and that's ultimately he's the boss.
The mental toughness that comes with that amateur wrestling background that we
were talking about.
It's really a,
it's a real thing.
It's real.
They are all of them.
All the Ma,
all,
all amateur wrestling champions are fucking mentally strong and special.
Special breed of human.
Absolutely.
And it's crazy.
It's like there's,
you know,
we're talking about how you should rest and you should train smart and you
shouldn't overtrain but it's like the overtraining is what made them so mentally
strong and that becomes one of their biggest weapons.
Yeah.
So it's such a catch 22
yeah.
I think that the genetic superiors rise in that area.
I think a lot of,
I mean,
not many guys actually make it to that,
the top of that podium and the genetic superiors make it to the top where
they're able to be the anomaly,
the outlier,
where the rest of us,
we're just not able to,
we break somewhere along the way due to whatever reason.
Um,
but it's not in their best.
I don't think it's,
it's part of the proper longevity protocol.
You know,
you see a lot of wrestlers in their fifties and sixties and they're kind of
fucked up.
Fucked up.
Dan Gables fucked up,
but they got Olympic gold metals and they have some things at,
some of us will never have.
So it's the risk reward.
Well,
Mark Coleman was like,
what,
48 49 he has a hip replacement already.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Yeah,
it's crazy.
It's still wrestling with this.
He's,
he's a crazy,
crazy bitch.
Right?
He's an animal.
Same
thing we were talking about that just a tough mother fuckers.
Um,
this,
I dunno if this is real or not,
um,
is,
or I have a question.
Is there,
the is like a piece of protein.
I'm like say like a 10 ounces of fish versus 10 ounces of lamb or some or elk or
game meat.
Is there a higher quality protein and some protein more effective to some
animals?
Do they have more energy?
I mean is there more energy in a grass fed piece of beef versus a a corn fed
piece of beef?
Yes,
and this is now my opinion based upon a lot of scientific research.
There's other research that says the opposite.
So now we're just going to throw it up in the air.
So my philosophy,
the dolce diet principles,
number one is earth grown nutrients and that's eating real food from its natural
source in its natural habitat.
Raised and bred in the natural way.
You cannot beat that when it comes to nutrient quality nutrient density.
And that's what we always go after.
So I want line caught fish,
salmon primarily.
That's one of my top choice line.
Caught Salmon,
excellent grass fed beef.
And when I say grass fed beef or meat,
I want that roaming in,
you know,
the,
the trees somewhere.
And I want to,
you know,
take it out myself with a bow or with a bullet where it doesn't even know any
humans within a hundred miles.
That's the best possible.
So there's no anxiety,
there's no quarters.
All,
there's no stress state.
There's no,
you know,
it's eating the exact food it's supposed to be.
Um,
it has no illness,
no injuries,
no disease,
no chemicals.
Um,
same thing,
really anything with your vegetables,
with your spinach,
with your,
your blueberries,
the most natural cannot be beat.
And that's what really defines my knee.
That's the number one principle.
If you're only eating earth,
grow nutrients,
real food,
and you don't pay attention to the time of day,
you don't pay attention to the quantity,
you're going to be much better off than most of the other people.
But is there more energy and say like a piece of elk than there is in line
caught salmon?
Is there more energy and grass fed beef than there is in lamp?
Is that quantifiable?
I don't believe so.
And what we do is we eat as much of it in moderation as we can.
So I want the elk,
I want the salmon,
I want the lamb,
I want the chicken,
I want the Turkey,
I want all of it.
I don't want to have just the beef everyday and just the eggs every everyday
mixing it up.
You have to mix everything because each one has a different nutrient profile and
I want all of them.
No,
those nutrients to cycle through my body.
Not just one type because you can build up some sort of allergy,
um,
or you build up at a,
you can be creative deficiency.
So as much of everything as possible,
whatever's local is best.
What's ever in season is best because that again has a higher nutrient quantity.
So whatever's seasonal,
that's what we typically cycle through.
Have you ever had to work with someone like a Jake shields who tries to fight as
a vegan effect?
He sort of Vegan eats eggs.
Yeah,
I speak with Jake.
We've toyed with it a little bit.
Never worked together officially.
Do I work with any specific vegans?
No,
I do.
I mean,
not professional athletes,
but in you know,
our normal business that we do,
we have some vegans and that's pretty easy.
A lot of my recipes are Vegan centric,
um,
which is
easy to do.
But if you're a combat athlete,
it's really hard to excel.
It's possible if you're an outlier,
but it's very possible,
very hard to excel without that animal protein.
And most vegans agree with that.
It's very difficult unless you're dogmatic about your sourcing of nutrition,
it becomes a full time plus job in order to eat the right foods at the right
time and you'd have to go to the market and you always have to have that supply.
You can't miss meals because you,
Bonnie's is constantly breaking down.
And is it harder for them also to get a high enough calories from their proteins
and things like a little bit,
it's harder for them to get,
they have to have what's called complimentary proteins.
You have to get multiple nutrient sources in order to get all the,
the amino acids like pea protein and hemp protein and rice protein and all these
different,
exactly.
Souders and stuff.
So vegan need a very diverse diet in order to make sure they're getting all the
proper nutrients and just becomes a lot of work.
And Jake has said that it's just a lot of work.
And even then,
is it,
is it 100% what you would get if you were eating elk and steak and chicken?
And,
I don't believe so.
I think it's,
I personally,
and I've never lived at 12 month.
I've lived for three months as a Vegan and it was very difficult.
I leaned out,
I lost a lot of weight,
I lost a lot of power output.
My endurance went up.
I mean my,
my blood panel looked awesome,
so it was definitely a give and take.
Um,
I didn't do it for a full 12 months,
which I think would,
I would really have to go through all four seasons to truly understand and feel
it.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
so I know fits,
tried it for awhile,
but then he went back to meet.
He said he feels much stronger.
Much better.
Yeah.
You know,
there's so many vegans were like tweeting Fitch.
They were loving it,
that he was Vegan.
Like,
we love that you're a Vegan man.
It's amazing.
And then afterwards he's like,
fuck,
this sucked it hard.
Tell us,
wait,
I'm not as strong.
I'm not as a grant.
I don't have as much energy.
And it goes,
and now I feel much better now that I'm eating meat again.
And they're like,
sad face,
let's get bummed out.
If you're not a vegan anymore,
they get bought.
They,
when they lose one of the heirs,
they get fucking,
but they love when they get one.
But when they lose one man,
it hits them hard.
It's tough.
And I do believe that there's a life force also that comes from certain foods.
I do believe that,
and maybe it's a placebo,
if that's true,
that I think I've had this philosophy,
which total bro Science on my part,
but my philosophy is that things that run quicker or better for you,
because that's why there's a reward for getting them.
And that's why before people figured out nets and hooks and lines,
it's really hard to catch a fish.
And if you kind of fish fucking strong protein,
you catch a salmon.
It's very high in protein.
Hemp I printing eline essential fats.
I mean a piece of elk has less cholesterol and more protein in the same piece of
chicken that weighs the same amount that you can easily enough.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree with that.
And Bro Science,
absolutely.
But you know,
until science cheat the best shit for you.
Maybe we should start eating Cheetos today.
Maybe.
Well,
I know they'd eat mountain lion
mountain line.
Everybody thinks they're like hunters that kill mountain lions are assholes.
But first of all,
you need to control the mountain lion population.
Otherwise they kill all the deer.
They kill all the pigs,
they kill everything.
Mountain lions are motherfuckers,
but also people eat it.
They eat mountain lions supposed to be really delicious and never had it.
Never had it either.
Is that a Colorado thing?
No,
it's,
you know,
places like Colorado for sure.
Utah places where they hunted on a regular basis,
they choose a mountain lion,
um,
over a pig and a lot of places they really like it.
Yeah,
it's supposed to like the backstraps.
The loin from outlines supposed to be delicious.
We ran out of time.
My friend,
if people want to get ahold of you,
how do they get ahold of you on Twitter?
That's the dolce diet.com.
The dolce died on Twitter and Facebook and all the,
all the places that you don't want to then use that.
Your book that you have there.
That is,
that is for you my friend.
It's three weeks to shred it or a new book that's out right now.
It's,
it details the Tiago out of his weight cut and also the one I had done previous.
So it's the original in the expanded version.
Dude,
we could do about 15 more of these I'm sure.
And when more things come up and more issues nutritionally or exercise wise or
let's do it.
Absolutely.
Thank you very much my friend.
Really appreciate it.
Mike Dolce,
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you sir.
Um,
you know how to get ahold of him.
Thanks to our sponsors.
Thanks to Squarespace.
Go to squarespace.com and enter the code word Joe,
squarespace.com.
Enter the code word Joe for a free trial and 10% off your first purchase.
Thanks.
Also to legal zoom.
Use the Codeword Rogan in the referral box at checkout.
Save yourself some money.
I have friends,
Mina,
Mina.
Speaking of money,
you also save some money with naturebox.com forward slash Rogen.
Go there and get 50% off your month.
First box of nutritious and Yummy,
delicious shit.
Uh,
okay.
We will be back my friends,
many,
many podcasts this week.
Tim Barnett from Solo hunters is here on Thursday.
Joe Derosa will be here on Wednesday until then,
big kiss.
Have Fun.
Take care.
See Ya.